GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED WE
WERE WAITING FOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND.
AND.
.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL BLOCK AND
BEFORE.
.
BEFORE THE END OF MY STATEMENT
SO GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY.
THAT PAST FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN A
PERIOD OF IMPROVEMENTS ADDS CAL
THAT IMPROVING PERFORMANCE IN
ORGANIZATION ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
RE ORIENTING THE DEPARTMENT
TOWARD ITS PRIMARY MISSION
SERVING A CALIFORNIA VETERANS.
AMONG OTHER RECENT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS CALVET HAS
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVE CONDITIONS
ADD ITS NETWORK OF VETERANS
HOMES.
NOT OF THIS TRANSFORMATION COULD
IMPOSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
LEADERSHIP OF SECRETARY EMBOSSED
YANNI.
WHOSE BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCE
HAVE BEEN KEY TO SQUARING AWAY
THIS DEPARTMENT THE PERIOD OF
GOOD LEADERSHIP AND A WELL
FUNCTIONING DEPARTMENT IS
SOMETHING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF.
TO MAKE THE GREATEST AMOUNT OF
POSITIVE CHANGE POSSIBLE AND TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE STRUCTURES
AND PRACTICES IN PLACE THAT BE
THAT CAN KEEP THE DEPARTMENT ON
COURSE THROUGH EXPECTED AND
UNEXPECTED CHANGES.
AT MY REQUEST THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION UNDERTOOK A REVIEW OF
CALVET VETERANS HOMES AND
PUBLISHED TWO REPORTS LAST YEAR.
THAT INDICATE.
NO MATTER HOW YOU VIEW THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THERE IS A GREAT. DEAL OF
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT AT THE
HOMES. AND A PRESSING NEED TO
CHANGE IN ORDER TO MEET THE
FUTURE NEEDS.
OF CHANGING OF THE CHANGING
VETERAN POPULATION.
TO THAT END LAST SUMMER THE
LEGISLATURE IMPOSE A REQUIREMENT
ON CAL THAT TO DEVISE A MASTER
PLAN FOR BOTH THE OPERATION OF
THE HOMES AS THE SYSTEM. AND FOR
EACH HOME INDIVIDUALLY THAT PLAN
IS DUE BY JULY TWENTY NINETEEN.
BUT IT'S NEVER TOO EARLY TO
CHECK IN AND ENSURE THAT THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES AND SKILLS
ARE BEING APPLIED TO IT.
WITH THE VETERAN POPULATION OF
MORE THAN A MILLION AND WITH
MORE VETERANS COMING HOME FROM
THE LONGEST PERIOD OF CONFLICT
IN AMERICAN HISTORY OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS A GREAT.
AND GROWING LINE AND I WANT TO
DO EVERYTHING I CAN'T TO PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE TO OUR
VETERANS WITH THAT.
.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
FOR CO HOSTING THIS HEARING.
AND ABSURD BONTA WALK IN THE
DOOR. A ON CALIFORNIA VETERAN
HOMES AND THE MEMBERS OF BOTH
THE VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
BUDGET SUB FOR COMMITTEE AND.
.
OTHER MEMBERS THAT SHOULD BE
SHOWING UP AT ANY MOMENT THERE'S
ANOTHER HEARING GOING ON THAT'S
APPARENTLY MUCH MORE.
.
ENTERTAINING.
IT IS MY HONOR TO CONTINUE TO
ASSEMBLY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AND WE ARE GOING TO
START THIS HEARING WITH AN
UPDATE FROM CAL THAT THEN HEAR
FROM MEMBERS OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION. THE ALEJO AND
THE VETERAN RESOURCE CENTER
CENTERS OF AMERICA.
AND SO WHY DON'T WE FIRST CALL
UP OUR SECRETARY.
DOCTOR A VETO AND BOSQUE YANNI.
.
TO GIVE US AN UPDATE.
GOOD AFTERNOON
.
NICE TO SEE SO MANY.
FAMILIAR FACES COMING BACK.
THE WORLD OF VETERANS.
REVENUE MADAM CHAIR IRWIN.
OF ANTICIPATED RIVAL OF CHAIRMAN
COOPER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND.
A THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
VETERANS IN THE ROOM FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
FIRST OFF.
BUT THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO IS TO
PROVIDING THE BEST SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS.
I APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE FURTHER IN AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE FUTURE
OF OUR STATEWIDE VETERANS HOME
SYSTEM.
WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT OUR STATE KEEPS
ITS PROMISE TO THOSE WHO SERVE
ON OUR BEHALF.
I AM EXCITED.
TO COME BEFORE YOU TODAY. JIM
COOPER.
AND I HAVE HAPPY NEWS.
ALL.
OF OUR CMS RATED HOMES
ARE NOW RATED AT FOUR OR FIVE
STARS.
PUTTING HIM AMONG THE TOP
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES IN
THE NATION.
I'D LIKE TO CONGRATULATE HIM
PUBLICLY THANK THE LEADERS OF
ARE VETERANS HOMES AND THEY'RE
DEDICATED STAFF ON THIS
REMARKABLE SUCCESS.
BOB AND THAT INCLUDES BY DEPUTY
SECRETARY TO MY RIGHT.
JACOBY PETERSON.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
SOUND RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS SUCH AS
YOURSELVES. AND BY OVERSIGHT
BODIES SUCH AS THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
AND TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
VERY CONSIDERED AND THOUGHTFUL
COUNCIL. REGULAR REVIEW OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES PROVIDED
BY THE STATE IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT.
FINALLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE IMPORTANT POLICY
DECISIONS WHICH WE SHOULD MAKE
CONSCIOUSLY AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WHICH IS WHY HEARINGS LIKE THIS
TODAY. ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
CALVET HAS ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH
IN RECENT YEARS AND SINCE YOU'VE
GIVEN ME THE MICROPHONE FOR A
FEW MINUTES.
I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
REFLECT ON THE LAST TWO YEARS
PARTICULARLY.
I AM PROUD TO REPORT THE
FOLLOWING.
THE NEWEST VETERANS HOMES
THOSE IN REDDING AND FRESNO.
WHICH HAD SAT VACANT FOR
SOMETIME DURING THE DEPTH OF
BUDGET AUSTERITY. HAVE NOW
REACHED THEIR FULL CAPACITY AND
TOGETHER ARE SERVING UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY VETERANS.
THE REMAINING TWO SKILLED
NURSING UNITS AT THE WEST LA
HOME. WHICH WILL ADD AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY FOUR BEDS ARE
POISED TO OPEN EMINENTLY PENDING
FINAL STATE INSPECTION.
OUR APPLICATION FOR WHICH IS
PENDING WITH CD P. H..
WE MADE EXCELLENT PROGRESS IN
STANDARDIZING OPERATIONS IN ALL
OF THE VETERANS HOMES. ALLOWING
US TO IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT
BEST PRACTICES.
SUCH AS IN NURSING CARE AND
PHARMACY PRACTICES.
ALSO WE'VE CREATED THE FIRST
DEDICATED REGULATORY DEVELOPMENT
TEAM AT CAL THAT. WITH THE
RECENT AUGMENTATION TO OUR
BUDGET FOR THAT PURPOSE.
MULTIPLE REGULATORY INITIATIVES
ARE NOW IN DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE PACE IS PROJECTED TO
CONTINUE FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
I'M PROUD OF THIS WORK IT WILL
BRING ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY TO
OUR OPERATIONS
CLARIFY ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS
FOR THE HOMES. AND PRIORITIZE
ADMISSIONS AND BOTTOM LINE IT'S
JUST GOOD GOVERNMENT.
LAST YEAR WE WORKED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO UPDATE THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS CODE.
ALLOWING CALVET TO OPERATE MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND REFINE OUR
ADMISSIONS CRITERIA TO ENSURE WE
FIRST SERVE THOSE VETERANS WHO
HAVE THE GREATEST NEED. AND WHO
SACRIFICE THE MOST.
OUR AGENCY IS ADOPTING AND
EXPANDING TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS TO INCREASE EFFICIENCY
AND PROVIDE BETTER SERVICES.
OUR TELEMEDICINE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE VA NOW SERVES FOR
VETERANS HOMES.
WE'VE COMPLETED THE INSTALLATION
OF AN AUTOMATED PHARMACY SYSTEM
WIDE.
AND WE'VE BEGUN TO WORK ON AN
ONLINE PORTAL TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR ALL VETERANS TO APPLY FOR
ADMISSION AND TO DETERMINE THEIR
PLACE ON THE WAITLIST.
OUR ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD
PROJECT IS ENTERING THE
PROCUREMENT PHASE AND WE EXPECT
THE ROLL OUT TO BEGIN LATER THIS
YEAR WITH PILOT PROJECTS.
WE HAVE A BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE PRIVATE ROOMS
FOR ALL SINGLE RESIDENTS IN
YOUNG FILLS DOMICILIARY.
PROVIDING A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE THAT REFLECTS THE CHANGING
DEMAND FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
WE'RE MAKING THE NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS TO PROTECT THE WATER
SUPPLY FOR THE VETERANS HOME TO
MODERNIZE DAM OPERATIONS. AND TO
ENHANCE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
TOWN OF YOUNTVILLE.
ALL WHILE PROVIDING ABOUT
PRESERVING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY OF THE WATERSHED.
AND FINALLY.
AS YOU ALL KNOW CALVET HAS AN
ITEM IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET.
FUND THE REPLACEMENT OF YOU
DON'T BILLS NOW OVER ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY YEAR OLD SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY BUILDING.
IT SUMMARY MY TENURE THUS FAR AS
SECRETARY OF CALVET. HAS BEEN
TRULY REWARDING PARTICULARLY.
WITH REGARD TO THE VETERANS
HOMES.
MY TOP PRIORITY IS NOW A
REALITY.
EIGHT VETERANS HOMES ALL OF HIGH
QUALITY SPANNING THE STATE FROM
READING TO CHILL OF VISTA AND
OFFERING CULTURALLY COMPETENT.
WARM AND HOME LIKE CARE IN
BEAUTIFUL BEAUTIFUL CALIFORNIA
SETTINGS.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW HOWEVER THAT
WE HAVE NOT AS SOLDIERS OFTEN
SAY DROPPED OUR PACKS
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE A TREE
ACHIEVE SO MUCH SO MANY BIG
GOALS FOR THE HOMES.
RATHER WITH OUR EIGHT HOMES
OPENING AND THRIVING WE MUST NOW
BEGIN TO CHART A COURSE FORWARD
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE FUTURE
NEEDS OF VETERANS IN THIS STATE.
KNOWING THIS
CALVET HAS BEGUN TO EVALUATE AND
RESEARCH THE EVOLUTION OF THE
HOMES.
EVEN BEFORE NEW LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR MANDATE THAT A FORMAL
PLANNING PROCESS BE PUT IN
PLACE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CALVET
BROUGHT INTO RETIRED ANNUITANTS
WHO SPECIALIZED IN DEMOGRAPHICS
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF MENTAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THEIR
RESEARCH REINFORCED WHAT WE
SUSPECTED?
SPECIFICALLY.
THE DEMAND FOR SKILLED NURSING
CARE MEMORY CARE AND MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WILL CONTINUE
TO BE HIGH FOR YEARS TO COME.
AND SECOND DEMAND FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING WILL CONTINUE
TO DECREASE.
AS PEOPLE AGE PAY PREFERRED TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES UNTIL THEY
ABSOLUTELY REQUIRE SKILLED
NURSING OR SIMILAR INSTITUTIONAL
MEDICAL SUPPORT IN A FACILITY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE MANDATES IN
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET.
CALVET HAS RETAINED AND
EXPERIENCED RESEARCHER WHO HAS
BEGUN DEVELOPING THE REQUISITE
SYSTEMIC AND HOME SPECIFIC
MASTER PLANS.
WE WERE VERY FORTUNATE TO FIND A
FORMER STATISTICIAN AND STUDY
COORDINATOR. FROM THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
WHO POSSESSES EXTENSIVE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE VA'S CLINICAL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE DATA SYSTEMS
PARTICULARLY THE USE OF DATA IN
PROGRAM MANAGEMENT?
THE MASTER PLANNING PROCESS WILL
ALSO CONTINUE THE WORK WE BEGAN
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
TO ACCESS CURRENT AND FUTURE
LONG TERM CARE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA VETERANS.
THAT ASSESSMENT WILL BE OVERLAID
WITH AN ANALYSIS OF OUR CURRENT
CAPABILITIES AND THOSE OF OUR
PARTNERS AT THE FEDERAL AND
LOCAL LEVELS.
THE ASSESSMENT WILL INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT WAIT LISTS FOR
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF CARE AND THE
IMPACT OF THE NEW ADMISSION
PRIORITIES THAT ARE VETERANS
HOMES.
TO OVERLY SIMPLIFY WE HOPE TO
LEARN WITH GREATER CLARITY WHAT
KIND OF LONG TERM CARE OUR
VETERANS WILL NEED MOST.
WHERE IN THE STATE THEY WILL
NEED IT AND WHAT SERVICE GAPS
ARE LIKELY TO EMERGE?
FURTHERMORE.
WE EXPECT THE PLANNING PROCESS
TO ANSWER SUCH QUESTIONS AS.
WILL THE LOCATION AND THE MIX OF
LEVELS OF CARE OFFERED IN OUR
CURRENT HOMES
MEET THE PROJECTED NEEDS OF
VETERANS FOR LONG TERM CARE.
WHAT FISCAL IMPACT WILL RESULT
FROM PRIORITIZING VOTE VETERANS
WITH HIGHER DISABILITY RATINGS
AND LEVELS OF FINANCIAL NEED?
AND FINALLY WATER THE PROJECTED
COSTS OF THE VARIOUS MODELS.
THE EXISTING HOMES PRESENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVOLUTION AS
THE CHAIRMAN STATED.
THESE MIGHT INCLUDE BRINGING
TOGETHER IN ONE PLACE
COMPLEMENTARY VETERAN SERVICES
SUCH AS NONPROFIT SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS.
VETERAN AN EMPLOYEE HOUSING AND
OTHER VENTURES THAT COULD RESULT
IN COST SAVINGS AND REVENUE
GENERATION.
OUR MASTER PLANNING SHOULD
RESULT IN A RANGE OF
ALTERNATIVES WHICH WE WILL PUT
FORWARD FOR CONSIDERATION.
ULTIMATELY I FORESEE THAT CALVET
WILL MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE ABOUT
THE OPTIMAL USE OF HOPE OF THE
HOMES IN THE FUTURE.
COLLECTIVELY WE WILL THEN HAVE
THE NECESSARY POLICY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS
WHICH I HOPE WILL LEAD TO AN
INFORMED CONSENSUS.
IN I RECEIVED A DOZEN QUESTIONS
FOR TO CONSIDER BEFORE TODAY'S
HEARINGS.
I READ THE MALL AND I WOULD
SUMMARIZE MOST OF THEM THIS WAY.
SECRETARY BASANTI IF THE MASTER
PLAN RESULTS IN A RADICALLY
DIFFERENT VERSION VISION OF THE
HOMES.
WOULD IT NOT BE BEST TO WAIT.
FOR THAT FINAL VISION TO EMERGE
BEFORE MAKING ANY.
POTENTIAL CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS.
SUCH AS A NEW SNIFF.
QUESTION.
MY IMMEDIATE RESPONSE WOULD BE
THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD TO WAIT.
IF THERE WERE NO VETERANS HOMES.
AND IF THE HOMES ARCHITECTURE
WERE BEING CREATED OPOVO FROM
SCRATCH TODAY. AND MAPPED OUT
UPON A FRESH BLANK PAGE
WAITING WOULD IN FACT BE THE
MOST PRUDENT COURSE OF ACTION.
HOWEVER THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS.
WE'RE NOT STARTING WITH A TABULA
RASA.
YOUNG FELIZ FAR FROM A BLANK
PAGE.
SOME OF YOUNG FILLS FEATURES
ALREADY EMBODIED DECADES EVEN A
CENTURY OF ARCHITECTURAL
TRADITIONS AND GROWTH.
AND FURTHERMORE.
SOME REPRESENT LARGE PRE
EXISTING CAPITAL INVESTMENTS OR
ARE THE SUBJECT OF LONG TERM
LEASES.
YES
THERE'S A BOUNTY OF UNDEVELOPED
SPACE ON THE CAMPUS ROOM FOR NEW
IDEAS AND EVEN SOME ABILITY TO
REPURPOSE EXISTING BUILDINGS.
NEVERTHELESS THERE ARE CERTAIN
FEATURES OF THE OWN FILL CAMPUS
LANDSCAPE WHICH AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER ARE IMMUTABLE.
AS THE OLDEST AND LARGEST
FACILITY OF ITS KIND IN THE
NATION THE ON FIELD VETERANS
HOME HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
FLAGSHIP OF THE CALVERT SYSTEM.
IT HAS PROVIDED CARE AND
SERVICES IN AN ICONIC SETTING
FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY YEARS.
HOWEVER AS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE VERY WELL AWARE THE CAMPUS
HAS A NUMBER OF PHYSICAL
CHALLENGES.
THE BUILDINGS ARE OLD. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INEFFICIENT
AND THE DESIGN REFLECTS BUILDING
STANDARDS OF GENERATIONS PAST.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE PARTICULAR
CASE OF THE YOUNG FILL STAFF.
THE BUILDING WHICH IS HOME TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE VETERAN
RESIDENTS ALSO HAS SERIOUS ACUTE
AND COSTLY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUE.
THIS IS THE REALITY.
SIMPLY PUT WE CANNOT AND SHOULD
NOT WAIT FOR THE OUTCOME OF AN
EXTENDED PRODUCT PLANNING
PROCESS WHICH I AM CONVINCED
THAT MY HEART WILL NOT DEVIATE
FROM OUR PRE. PRESUPPOSITIONS
BEFORE REPLACING THE EXISTING
SNIFF BUILDINGS.
HERE WE ARE TODAY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DISCUSSING THIS.
WHAT CALVET RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT
OF THE ANFAL CAMPUS AS FAR BACK
AS TWO THOUSAND TWELVE?
IT CONTRACTED THEN WITH AN
ARCHITECTURAL AND ENGINEERING
FIRM HELLMUTH OBATA AND
KASSEBAUM TO DEVELOP A LONG TERM
MASTER PLAN FOR THE PROPERTY.
THIS MASTER PLAN RESULTED IN AN
EXPERT.
ROAD MAP
HIGHLIGHTING THE MOST URGENT AND
BENEFICIAL PROJECTS THAT WOULD
BRING THE DOWNFALL CAMPUS TO ITS
FULL POTENTIAL INCLUDING
REPLACEMENT OF THE SNIFF
BUILDING.
SO THE CURRENT BOLD
BOTH THE CURRENT BUDGET IS THE
FIRST TO SEEK APPROVAL FOR THIS
NEW STAFF.
THERE WERE ACTUALLY YEARS A
PRIOR CALVET PLANNING WHICH LED
TO THIS PCP.
FINALLY AS THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZED IN HIS PROPOSED
BUDGET A DELAY IN REPLACING THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY WOULD
BE A FAILURE TO PROVIDE THAT TO
PROVIDE THE BEST CARE FOR OUR
VETERANS. AND WOULD BE A WASTE
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
WHY SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
MORE THAN EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
HAS BEENSENT SPENT ON
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS TO PATCH
YOUNG FILLS ANTIQUATED
FACILITIES? JUST TO KEEP THE
HOME OPERATING.
YES I'M PROUD THAT WE HAVE
MANAGED TO PROVIDE FIVE STAR
CARE USING PATCHWORK AND
MAKESHIFT REPAIRS. HOWEVER THIS
IS NOT A SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION.
IN ADDITION TO THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THE SNIFF
REPLACEMENT.
WE CANNOT IGNORE THE
EXPECTATIONS OF OUR MOST
INDEPENDENT RESIDENTS.
FOR THEIR WELL DESERVED QUALITY
OF LIFE.
RESIDENTS IN OUR DOMICILIARY
PROGRAM MAY NOT REQUIRE ROUND
THE CLOCK ATTENTION FROM OUR
NURSES.
BUT YOU DON'T FILL IS THEIR HOME
AND THEY HAVE HEARD EARNS THE
VERY BEST WE CAN OFFER.
THE CURRENT DOMICILIARY BUILDING
CONFIGURATION IS BUILT ON A
MILITARY BARRACKS MODEL WHICH IS
OUTDATED EVEN ON MODERN MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS AND WHICH
CERTAINLY DOES NOT REFLECT THE
STANDARDS WHICH GUIDE
CONSTRUCTION OF A SIMILAR. LONG
TERM BECAUSE A CARE FACILITY
TODAY.
TO THAT END WE HAVE PROPOSED
MODIFYING OUR ROOM ASSIGNMENTS
SO THAT EACH OF THESE RESIDENTS
HAS HIS OR HER OWN ROOM.
THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE IN PART BY
A DROP IN THE DEMAND FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING.
RECONFIGURING OUR INDEPENDENT
LIVING BUILDINGS TO A SINGLE
OCCUPANCY MODEL. REPRESENTS A
CHANGE THAT IS MUCH EASIER AND
MORE AFFORDABLE THAN A MAJOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT.
YET MAKE NO MISTAKE IT WILL MEAN
A WORLD OF IMPROVEMENT FOR THESE
VALUED MEMBERS OF OUR HOME.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN
THE DOMICILIARY SETTING WITH
THEIR SPOUSES.
AND THIS MOVE TOWARD SINGLE
ROOMS WILL NOT AFFECT COUPLES.
THE INITIATIVES FOR SNIFF AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING THE BOOKENDS
OF OUR LONG TERM CARE OFFERINGS
CANNOT WAIT.
OTHER REFINEMENTS AND EVOLUTIONS
IN THE HOMES ARE CLEARLY NEEDED
TO ADDRESS THE CHANGING NEEDS OF
OUR VETERANS. WE EMBRACE THE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES TO PLAN FOR
THEM.
WHERE ENCOURAGED BY THE WEALTH
OF SUPPORT AND THE OUT POURING
OF IDEAS FROM THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND BEYOND? AND WE
KNOW THAT THE VAST DOWNFALL
CAMPUS IN PARTICULAR OFFERS AN
ABUNDANCE OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SENSIBLE AND FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THROUGH THE MASTER PLANNING
PROCESS WE ARE EXPLORING A
MULTITUDE OF IDEAS THAT ARE IN
KEEPING WITH OUR MISSION. AND
WHICH WOULD ALLOW CALVET TO
EXPAND OUR SERVICES TO ALL
VETERANS IN THE REGION.
GIVEN ITS SIZE ITS LOCATION AND
THE IMPRESSIVE DEGREE OF
COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
BEYOND FILL CAMPUS SHOW STRONG
POTENTIAL FOR THESE TYPES OF
PARTNERSHIPS.
AND
OUR TOUCHSTONE THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS
IS THE PRINCIPLE THAT THE ON
FILL CAMPUS MUST BE USED TO
SERVE VETERANS.
THE VETERANS HOME OF CALIFORNIA
ALREADY TURNING POINT IN THEIR
HISTORY.
WE'VE ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF
THE PAST AND BROUGHT FIVE NEW
HOMES ONLINE WHILE PROVIDING
EXCELLENT HEALTH CARE IN THE
MEANTIME.
NOW IS THE TIME TO PURSUE IDEAS
FOR THE FUTURE. AND TO RECOMMIT
TO INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS FOR THE DECADES TO COME
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
DISCUSSION THIS IS A VERY
EXCITING TIME FOR CALL THAT. AN
I ALONG WITH MY ENTIRE
LEADERSHIP TEAM AND PROUD PLAY A
ROLE IN ITS FUTURE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOCTRINE BOSC YANNI AND.
MY.
COCHAIR LE THE CHAIR OF BUDGET
SUB FOUR WOULD LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS BEFORE WE TAKE QUESTIONS
FROM.
THE OTHER MEMBERS EXECUTIVE
MISTER SECRETARY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FOR CLOSE
TING IT'S IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
HEARING. ON CALIFORNIANS
VETERANS HOMES ISN'T A VETERAN
ANOTHER ISSUES ALL TOO WELL.
BOTH POLICY AND BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HAVE IMPORTANT ROLE
VENTURING THAT FUNDING WE HAVE
THE AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE STATE'S
VETERANS.
SPEND A MANNER AS EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE.
LET FOUR TO WORKING ON THE
VETERANS ISSUES AGAIN THIS YEAR
THE BUDGET PROCESS.
LESTER TOWARD THE ALPHA HOME
WITH THE SECRETARY
TODAY'S HEARING IS A GREAT PLACE
TO BEGIN THE CONVERSATION IN
BUDGET SUB FOR WILL TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS. THAT SERVE OUR
VETERANS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
IT'S CABALLERO IMAGE THIS
ACTUALLY BE MAY BE MORE IN THAT
IN THAT.
FRAMEWORK OF A OF A OF IT
STATEMENT BECAUSE I'M. I'M I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY.
IT'S UP.
TAPE THAT WOULD CLEAR TO ME THAT
TIME YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND WHAT
CONCERNS ME IS THAT TIME.
.
IN OUR REGION IN THEM IN THE
THIRTIETH ES DE WE HAVE A HIGH
NUMBER OF VETERANS THAT ARE
HOMELESS.
AND WE STRUGGLE WITH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THE SERVICES
THEY MOST NEED AND WE HAVE SOME
PRETTY GOOD FACILITIES AND
LOCATED IN IN MONTEREY COUNTY.
BUT BUT I LOOK AT THE.
I DID SOME MATH AND IT'S CLOSE
TO THE NUMBERS THAT ARE LISTED
ON OUR REPORT UP CLOSE TO
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR.
THE RESIDENTIAL.
FACILITY FOR THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR.
INDIVIDUALS THAT LIVE IN AND I
AM.
IN THE HOUSING FOR SO IN THE
HOUSE FACILITIES.
.
MAY IT'S IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE
LONG TERM
IF WE IF WE HAD THE HOUSE ALL
ONE POINT SEVEN ONE MILLION VETS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ON
WE'D HAVE TO USE THE ENTIRE
STATE BUDGET IN ORDER TO DO
THAT'S I GUESS.
IT AS AS WE LOOK FORWARD I'M
VERY INTERESTED IN HEARING UP
WHAT SOME OF THE ALTERNATIVES
ARE.
TO PROVIDING SERVICES AND IN A
REALLY HOW COME WE DO THE MOST
THAT WE CAN FOR VETERANS.
.
WHO?
WHO REALLY AREN'T HAVE GONE
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE CALL OF
DUTY OF MOST?
CITIZENS THAT LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY PUT THEMSELVES IN HARM'S
WAY AND AND WE KNOW THAT THE
MORE RECENT WARS HAVE BEEN EVEN
MORE DEVASTATING.
IT MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY ON
THE RETURNING VETERAN SO I I
GUESS MY.
AB ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
IS WHETHER OTHER STATES DOING.
ARE THEY. ARE THEY DOING A
BETTER JOB OF OF PROVIDING
SERVICES TO VETERANS IN NEED AND
HOW CAN WHETHER THE RESOURCES
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
IDENTIFY AND MAYBE THE REPORT
WILL TELL US IN A IN A YEAR AND
A HALF. WHERE WE OUGHT TO DEPLOY
SOME OF OUR RESOURCES BUT I'M
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LONG TERM?
M. STRATEGY FOR HOUSING
VETERANS AND THEN REALLY GETTING
THEM BACK.
AND INTEGRATED INTO SOCIETY.
I THINK YOU'RE SOME OF OUR THAT
THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY BROAD
QUESTION AND BY THE WAY I AM.
YOU CAN INVITE ME BACK WELL IN
ADVANCE OF THAT EIGHTEEN MONTH.
DEADLINE TO GET PROGRESS REPORTS
I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT ME POINT.
BY.
I AUTUMN.
YOU'VE RACED.
YOU'VE RAISED ONE MAJOR ISSUE
WHICH IS VETERANS SERVICES WE
HAVE ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
VETERANS.
THANK THE GOOD LORD TO OF THEY
ALL DO NOT REQUIRE CAL THAT'S
ASSISTANCE WITH THEIR HOUSING
AND WE HAVE A HOME MORTGAGE
PROGRAM THERE ARE MANY
SUCCESSFUL VETERANS OUT THERE.
WHO DO NOT COME BACK?
ANNA SIGNIFICANTLY IMPAIRED ARE
THRIVING IN THE WORKPLACE THEY
CAN APPLY FOR COMMERCIAL OR
MORTGAGES ON WE ADDRESSED.
CALVET ADDRESSES THE HOUSING.
ISSUE.
IN A VAST SPECTRUM IF YOU WILL
FROM EVEN A EMERGING HOUSING THE
VETERAN THAT NEEDS A HOW. A ROOF
OVER HIS HEAD TONIGHT.
IF WE CAN REACH THE VETERAN OF
THE VETERAN CAN REACH ANYONE IN
AUTHORITY. THERE IS A SYSTEM IN
PLACE FROM OREGON TO THE MEXICAN
BORDER THAT WILL GET A VETERAN
INTO HOME OF A PLACE.
TONIGHT
WE HAVE.
WE CAN TAKE THEM IN FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME EITHER
TRANSITIONAL.
HOUSING OR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AND THEN WE GO ALL THE WAY ON UP
THROUGH RENTAL HOUSING THROUGH
HUD VOUCHERS AND AND SO ON. TOM.
CHAU.
A PROBLEM DE IT WOULD WITH SOME
OF THE VETERANS THAT ARE
HOMELESS IS THAT. WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE AND
THEY DON'T REACH OUT TO US OR
THEY REFUSE THE OFFER.
SO. BUT WE HAVE CAPACITY THROUGH
OUR IT NOT JUST IN CALVET BUT
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH JUSTIN Y.
LOS ANGELES ALONE.
THE SALVATION ARMY.
IN ORANGE COUNTY IT WOULD BE
GOOD WILL THERE ARE NETWORKS OF
PLACES WILL WEAKEN HOUSE ANY
HOMELESS VETERAN WHO PRESENTS TO
US TODAY IN A SUSTAINABLE.
MANNER.
BUT YOUR OTHER ISSUE I I THOUGHT
YOU WERE GONNA ASK HOW CAN WE
SUSTAIN THE HOMES.
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE.
YOUR QUESTION IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
ONE.
WHY DO WE HAVE HOMES WE DON'T%
HAVE HOMES BECAUSE WE LIKE
TAKING CARE VETERANS IN OUR
HOMES WE HAVE HOMES BECAUSE THIS
COUNTRY THROUGH ITS POLICY ITS
FOREIGN POLICY IN ITS MILITARIES
POLICY? PUT YOUNG AMERICAN MEN
AND WOMEN IN HARM'S WAY THEY
COME BACK BROKEN IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER PHYSICALLY OR MENTALLY.
IT IS OUR OBLIGATION AS ABRAHAM
LINCOLN SAID TO CARE FOR THOSE
WHO BORE THE BATTLE WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IT IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION TO DO IT. THE
VETERANS HOMES IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN EVERY OTHER STATE IN THE
UNION HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
SPECIAL TALENT OUR HOMES ARE NOT
ORDINARY NURSING HOMES
WE CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT. THE
THE OUR VETERANS IN THE HOMES
HAVE SOMETIMES FAILED AT OTHER
NURSING HOMES HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
LEAVE BECAUSE.
THEIR PARTICULAR.
NEEDS AS A VETERAN ARE NOT IT
THESE ARE FOR PRIMORDIAL NEEDS
ARE FUNDAMENTAL NEEDS ARE NOT
BEING ADDRESSED.
THE VETERANS HOME IT YOUNTVILLE
HAS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY YEARS
OF EXPERTISE ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THOSE PEOPLE.
BUT YES ASSEMBLY MARK THE
MEDICAL CARE FOR VETERANS IS
EXPENSE OF.
AND A LOT OF MY BUDGET GOES TO
TAKE CARE OF A FEWER THAN THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. WHEN THEY'RE SO
MANY OTHER VETERANS WE ARE
DEVELOPING OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE
THE CAL TECH THE TRANSITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT WILL.
MASSIVELY AUGMENT MY ABILITY TO
REACH AND PROVIDE SERVICES AND
CONNECT VETERANS TO SERVICES FOR
THE OTHER ONE POINT SIX NINE
FIVE MILLION VETERANS.
A WHO DON'T NEED HOUSING BUT FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE THE
DESTITUTE THE ALONE THE
HOMELESS.
THE PEOPLE WITH NO ONE ELSE IN
THE WORLD WHO A. WE HAVE A PLACE
FOR THEM THAT COMES WITH A PRICE
TAG IT'S A PRICE OF EVERY STATE
THE UNION IS WILLING TO PAY.
YOUR QUESTION WAS SO BRED BUT I
HOPE I CHIPPED AWAY AT CORNERS
OTHER I I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THE MISSION AND I APPRECIATE.
.
THE THE THE THE THE HOMES AND
ALL OF THE WORK THAT THEY DO I
GUESS WHAT I WAS GETTING TO IS.
.
IS THAT I I'VE I'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK RUN HOMELESS ISSUE AND.
IT'S NEWS TO ME THAT ANY
VETERAN ANY NIGHT OF THE WEEK
CAN GET. A SHELTER SO SO LET ME
JUST SAY THAT THAT THAT'S NEWS
TO ME AND MAYBE I CAN TAKE IT
BACK TO RURAL COMMUNITIES WHERE
WE WE. WE STRUGGLE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO SHOW
THEM THAT'S INCUMBENT ON US I
NEED TO EDUCATE EVERYONE IN THE
STATE WHAT THAT NETWORK IS IF I
COULD IF I COULD INSTANTLY HAVE
A TWO ONE ONE SYSTEM THAT THEY
HAVE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. WHERE
YOU CAN CALL THAT SYSTEM AND SAY
I NEED FOOD AND YOU'RE DIRECTED
TOWARD US FOOD STAMP PROGRAM I
NEED HOUSING I NEED A JOB? IF I
CAN EXPORT THAT TO THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SOMEBODY WHO
SAID I NEED A ROOF OVER MY HEAD
TODAY WOULD BE DIRECTED TO THEIR
LOCAL COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICER. THEIR LOCAL LINK WE
HAVE EIGHT EMPLOYEES OF MY
AGENCY WHO SORT OF SHEPHERD
LARGE NUMBERS OF CANDIES ARM AND
WHO ARE PHYSICALLY RESPONSIVE.
DURING THE FIRES EARTHQUAKES AND
FLOODS IT'S OUR LINKS MCV ESOS
FROM THE COUNTIES WHO GO INTO
THE MUD AND INTO THE ASHES AND
MAKE SURE THAT LEAST THE
VETERANS.
HAVE SUPPORT AND HAVE A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD BUT IT.
A WHAT YOU'RE ASKING OR WHAT OF
THE LINES OF CONNECTION TO HELP.
I CAN HELP WITH THAT RIGHT THAT
THAT WOULD BE REALLY I THINK
VERY GOOD IN AND THE OTHER THE
OTHER ISSUE IT JUST REALLY HAS
TO DO WITH. WHERE WHERE THERE?
UNMET NEEDS AND WHERE THERE
ACCESS RESOURCES AND AND I DON'T
MEAN EXCESS RESOURCES IN HIS AS
IN WE DON'T WE DON'T NEED THEM
AT THAT PARTICULAR. PLACE BUT
WHERE THERE ARE BEDS UNUSED.
THAT COULD BETTER BE USED RE
PURPOSED
UP AND AND AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
AS WELL YEAH. THAT'S THAT'S
CRUCIAL I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT YOU'RE ASKING
FOR A MASTER PLAN NOT JUST FROM
MY ENTIRE SYSTEM OF HOMES BUT
FOR INDIVIDUAL HOMES. WE NEED TO
START ASKING DO WE HAVE THE
RIGHT SERVICES ARE THEY IN THE
RIGHT PLACE FOR EXAMPLE WE HEAR
FROM VENTURA COUNTY AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY PARTICULARLY WE
NEED MORE MEMORY CARE FOR THE
VETERANS IN THOSE AREAS OKAY.
DULY NOTED ARMED BUT DE ARE THE
HOMES IN THE RIGHT PLACES.
BOB AND I I HAVE A HARD TIME
FILLING.
.
FILLING THE BEDS IN ONE HOME I
HAVE EXTRAORDINARY DIFFICULTY
RITA WHO.
RECRUITING AND RETAINING HELP
DOCTORS NURSES THERAPISTS
PHARMACISTS IN SEVERAL OF THE
HOMES BECAUSE EITHER OF
GEOGRAPHICAL CHALLENGES OR THE
HIGH COST OF LIVING AND LET'S
SAY IT LOS ANGELES AND NAPA
COUNTY.
WHERE ENTRY LEVEL CAL THAT
EMPLOYEES HAVE TO LIVE AT GREAT
DISTANCE
FROM THE WORKPLACE?
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
PHONE OBAMA'S GABRIELLE'S
QUESTION WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE OF SERVING OUR VETERANS.
THE GREATEST NEEDS BUT ALSO
PROVIDING SERVICES THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF MEMBERS.
HOW DISEASE BALLOTS BEING
REFLECTED IN THE MASTER PLAN?
REPLIED THE GREATEST.
S. ARE HIP IT'S WASN'T DOING FAR
BETTER IF THE GREATEST NEEDS BUT
ALSO PROVIDING SERVICES TO THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF MEMBERS.
WELL I AGREE AS I A GONNA START
BY SAYING I THINK I THINK THE
GOOD LORD THAT WE'D THAT NOT
EVERY VETERAN IN CALIFORNIA NEED
IS DESTITUTE.
SO MANY OF THEM ARE LEAVING
SUCCESSFUL LIVES IN THEIR JOBS
AND A AND THAT THEY DON'T NEED
HOUSING. BUT ALL OF THE OTHER
BENEFITS THAT THEY FOUGHT FOR
AND THEY EARNED WE DON'T GIVE
THEM ANY BENEFIT THAT THEY
HAVEN'T EARNED.
EDUCATION HOUSING.
JOB AYE. SECURITY EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING.
THAT'S ALL OF AN ASPECT OF THE
CORE WORK OF OUR AGENCY WHICH
IS.
OUTREACH TO VETERAN SERVICES
TO CONNECT VETERANS WITH THOSE
BENEFITS.
AND TO HELP THEM OVERCOME
OBSTACLES WHETHER THEY HAPPEN TO
HAVE A HARD TIME BECOMING A
CITIZEN WHICH THEY THOUGHT WAS
AUTOMATIC AFTER THE MILITARY
SERVICE. WHETHER THEY ARE
INCARCERATED THAN EXPECTED TO
GET OUT IN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
WHETHER THE WRITTEN A DIVERSION
COURT WHETHER THEY ARE A MEMBER
OF OF AN ISOLATED MINORITY OR
JUST ISOLATED ALPINE OR DESERT
COMMUNITIES WHETHER THEY ARE
NATIVE AMERICAN AN ISOLATED ON.
NATIVE AMERICAN HOMELANDS SO
WHERE.
WHO WE ARE THROUGH OUR
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH JUST WAS BORN
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE'S AND
PUT LAST YEAR AND IS JUST?
FIRST BUDS ARE STARTING TO OPEN
THE FIRST CURRICULUM IS BEING
DEPLOYED WE ARE AND NOW HAVE A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN.
AT SOME PENDLETON WHERE THREE
HUNDRED MARINES LEAVE MILITARY
SERVICE EVERY SINGLE MONTH WHERE
THERE EVERY SINGLE MONTH NOW TO
HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THEIR
BENEFITS BEFORE THEY TAKE THEIR
UNIFORM OFF. WERE JUST NOW GOING
TO VANDENBERG MARCH AIR FORCE
BASE WILL FOLLOW SO WILL THE
NAVY BASES AND SAN DIEGO AND
THEN THROUGH.
A CONCERT AT THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
LIBRARY SYSTEM WILL BE ABLE TO
EXPORT THIS EVEN TO MORE REMOTE
COMMUNITIES WHERE EVERY VETERAN
CAN CONNECT THAT. WE CAN DO A
BETTER JOB REACHING THE OTHER
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
IT'S MORE QUESTION CALVET HAS
SIGNIFICANT ASSETS SPECIAL
YOUNTVILLE.
AS FAR AS OPTIONS INCREASE
REVENUE WHEELER SOME LEASES THAT
YA'LL BILL THAT MAYBE ARE SO
FAVORABLE CAL THAT.
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE
STRUCTURED THROUGH SECRECY FAIR
MARKET VALUE FOR THOSE?
A GOOD QUESTION.
I IT'S IT'S NO SECRET DUBBED I.
READ SOME OF THE LEASES ON.
RELATED TO THE EIGHT ACTIVITIES
THAT GO ON ON THE OF VETERANS
CAMPUS OF THEIR IN. THEIR WHAT
TEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY YEARS
OLD.
THERE WHAT WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
UNFAVORABLE TERMS TO THE
VETERANS AT CAL THAT.
AT A
DOUG ONCE WE'RE DONE WITH THIS
SERIES OF HEARINGS I'M WORKING
WITH MY LAWYERS TO TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT THOSE LEASES AND SEE IF
WE CAN MAXIMIZE OUR INFLUENCE.
TO SEE IF WE'RE GETTING.
THE BEST.
OF BENEFIT WE CAN.
FROM THE LEASES.
I.
A PARTNERSHIP WAS MADE WITH THE
ENTITIES THAT CAME ON TO THE
CAMPUS.
PARTLY.
LET'S I HAVE TO BE HONEST PART
OF THE REASON THAT THERE THERE
IS THEY CAN AFFORD TO BE THERE
AND THEY DO OFFER BENEFITS.
SOME TO OUR VETERANS AND SOME
CLEARLY TO THE MUCH LARGER NAPA
COMMUNITY.
BOB.
SOME OF THEM RIGHT NOW SO
INTEGRATED THAT THE BASEBALL
FIELD THE SWIMMING POOL THE NAPA
MUSEUM THE.
THE FIFTH THE LINCOLN THEATER
THERE NOW INTERCULTURAL IT'S OF
THE.
THERE THE WOLFEN WHARF OF THE
FABRIC OF THAT COMMUNITY
SO I I I.
I TREAD CAREFULLY BUT I DO NEED
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE NEEDS OF
THE VETERANS. I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO ASK WHAT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES MIGHT THERE BE IN
THE FUTURE FOR NEW REVENUE
GENERATION AT THE CAMPUS AND.
.
AWARE OF THE MASTER PLAN IS
GOING TO HELP THE SPECIFIC
MASTER PLAN IS GOING TO HELP ME
ARM. LOOK INTO THAT. MORE
CAREFULLY.
WHERE IN THE PROCESS OF MANY
DISCUSSIONS SOME OF WHICH I FEEL
A LITTLE AWKWARD BECAUSE THEIR
PRELIMINARY?
WE'VE MADE SITE VISITS AND I
HAVE SPOKEN TO SISTER AGENCIES
THAT HAVE INVOLVED THEMSELVES IN
PARTNERSHIPS WITHOUT NONPROFITS
AND THE COMMUNITY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT THE.
THEY HELP US.
MORE.
IN LOOKING INTO THAT.
HOME. PUT.
I AGREE THERE IS
AN UNTAPPED I WOULD SAY VAST BUT
AN UNTAPPED POTENTIAL FOR
REVENUE GENERATION.
THINKS THE LEGISLATURE'S HELP
HIM.
JIGGLING AROUND OUR ADMISSIONS
CRITERIA WHERE WE NOW FAVOR
THOSE WHO LOST MORE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AS PRIORITIZE ATION
FOR ADMISSION. THAT WILL ENHANCE
FEDERAL PER DIEM REVENUE TO US.
AND.
.
AND I THINK.
YES RIGHT THANK YOU THE OTHER
YOU ALSO.
HELPED ME MANDATE THAT ALL
VETERANS HAVE FEDERAL STATE OR
PERSONAL INSURANCE.
ARM.
ADD TO MAXIMIZE REVENUE.
SO I EXPECT TO DO THAT RIGHT
NOW.
WHEN I CAME IN TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO WE WERE RECOUPING
THIRTY SIX CENTS ON EVERY DOLLAR
SPENT ON LOW. CHAIR AND I
CERTAINLY WANT THAT NUMBER TO GO
NORTH.
.
I THINK
SEVENTY PERCENT IS PROBABLY AN
UNREALISTIC.
.
GOAL BUT GETTING CLOSE TO FIFTY
PERCENT MIGHT NOT BE
UNREALISTIC.
HA ONE STATE NEW YORK STATE.
ES MAKES A PROFIT ON ITS
VETERANS HOME BUT ONLY BY
RESTRICTING ADMISSION TO THOSE
WITH SEVENTY PERCENT OR GREATER
DISABILITY. AND I THINK IF WE
WERE TO DO THAT.
.
I'M SORRY OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ACADEMIC CAN HEAR THIS LAST
REMARK WE WOULD.
.
WE WOULD HAVE TO NOT ACCEPT.
HOMELESS AND THINK ABOUT THIS
FOR EVERY HOMELESS BED I TAKEN
TO.
.
IN INTO SHELTER AT YOUNTVILLE OR
ANY OF MY HOMES YOU DON'T THINK
THAT THEY HAVE ASSETS THAT I CAN
TAP INTO FOR THE COST OF THEIR
CARE. IF THEY HAVE THOSE KIND OF
ASSETS THEY WOULDN'T BE
HOMELESS.
SO I'M CAUGHT BETWEEN A LITTLE
BIT OF A ROCK AND A HARD PLACE
THERE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MET MATHIS.
THE CHAIR.
DOCTOR VIA I I'VE GOT TO GO
BACK WITH THE HOME.
PART OF WHAT ASSEMBLY WILL.
MEMBER CAVALERA WAS SANE.
THERE ANY EFFORTS BEING DOWN BY
CAL THAT BEGIN TO TRACK COUNTY
VETERANS ARE COUCH SURFING AS AS
FAR AS THE HOMELESSNESS ON THAT
SIDE.
YES HOMELESSNESS ISN'T IS BEING
OUT ON THE STREET A LOT OF IT'S
YOU KNOW THEY. ARE STATE WANT
FRIENDS HOUSE AND THAT DOESN'T
WORK OUT THERE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
SO THEIR EFFORTS BEING DONE AT
ALL ON THAT AVENUE.
IN LIKE YOU SAID WE WE HAVE A
HOMELESS POPULATION HAVE A
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM IN THE
STATE.
THAT I KNOW A LOT OF US.
A LOT OF THE MEMBERS ON AND
BOTH HOUSES ARE WORKING TOWARDS
SOLVING THE STATE HOMELESS
PROBLEM.
AND DID TO THE COMMENT MADE OF
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
HOMELESS.
VETERANS OUT THERE THAT.
FOR WHATEVER REASON OF KINDA
FALLEN OFF THE TRACKS AND MAY
NOT BE ACTUALLY TAPPING INTO
THEIR BENEFITS AND I'VE SEEN
MANY CASES.
WITH THAT MY PASSED OUT BEFORE
BEING ELECTED WITH MY SIX YEARS
WORKING IN VETERANS ADVOCACY.
HOW IT WE SAW A LOT OF CASES OF
THAT WHERE SOMEBODY DIDN'T KNOW
OF A BENEFIT THAT THEY HAD?
OR AS THINGS CHANGE ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL NEW BENEFITS
BECOME AVAILABLE. AND IF YOU
HAVE A VETERAN THAT'S BEEN
HOMELESS FOR A WHILE THEY MAY
NOT KNOW OF THOSE CHANGES FOR.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU KNOW
WE REACH OUT TO THEM AND MAKE
SURE.
WELL THAT'S BEING DONE AND
THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THREE
QUESTIONERS COULD BUT WE START
WITH THAT ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATH AND THANK YOU OF COURSE FOR
YOUR YOUR SERVICE.
.
IF HE AYE.
WHERE TO START?
?
I HAVE I HAVE PEOPLE THAT YOU.
THE KEY TO THE ANSWER IS IN YOUR
FINAL A SENTENCE REACH OUT ARM.
WE DON'T KNOW EVERY VETERAN WHO
EVERY VETERAN IS IN CALIFORNIA
OUR ESTIMATE OF ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION COMES IT SAID WELL
GROUNDED ESTIMATED COMES FROM
THE THE DOD AND THE THE THE
SERVICES BRANCHES AND OUR. OUR
OWN INTERNAL A LOT OF PEOPLE
SELF IDENTIFY.
THERE'S NO WAY TO IDENTIFY LGBT
VETERANS UNLESS THEY IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES TO US IN OUR
QUESTIONNAIRES. ARM.
HOMELESS VETERANS.
IF THEIR COUCH SEARCHING ARE WE
HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING
CALIFORNIA JUST COMPLETED IT'S A
WHAT WE CALL A POINT AND KEPT
THEM.
THANK YOU THE POINT TOWN SURVEY
JUST A LAST WEEK. WHERE PEOPLE
GO OUT UNDER EVERY?
BUT. FOR ALL THE SHANTY TOWNS
AND OF THE TENT CITIES AND THE
UNDER PASSES AND THE BACKYARD
CHEN AND FIND HOMELESS PEOPLE
PEOPLE SLEEPING ON THE STREET.
AND THE THEY TRY TO GET SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OUT OF
THEM INCLUDING THE QUESTION HAVE
YOU EVER SERVED.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE
A WAY TO KNOW IF ANYONE IS COUCH
SURFING OR EVEN HOW MANY
HOMELESS VETERANS THERE ARE.
UNTIL THAT DATA COMES IN EVERY
YEAR AND IS. OF REFORM. REFINED.
DAWN BUT EVEN THAT WHICH. WE
ALWAYS SEEM TO DO A BETTER JOB
EVEN IN EDUCATING OUR VETERANS
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY WOMEN
VETERANS SAY TO ME I DIDN'T KNOW
I WAS A VETERAN I'M A WOMAN.
OR HOW MANY PEOPLE OF EITHER
GENDER SAY I WAS NEVER WOUNDED
HOW CAN I BE A VETERAN IT IT'S
IT SPEAKS TO A PROFOUND
IGNORANCE OF YOUR STATUS ANYTIME
YOU'RE BENEFITS BUT.
SO SO WAIT WITH THAT.
THIS PAST YEAR WE PASSED.
LEGISLATION TO START TRACKING
THE TWENTY TWO A DAY.
WITH THE VETERANS SUICIDE IS
ARE WE IN ANY NUMBERS.
AND ON THAT YEAH AND WHAT IS THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE IT
BEGAN.
GATHERING THAT DATA.
BOB WELL OF I I WASN'T ACTUALLY
PARA TO GO VERY MUCH OUTSIDE THE
HOMES BUT.
LIFE AND DEATH ISSUES TAKE
PRIORITY ARMED SHOWED. IT IS NOW
HERE SO YOU KNOW IT'S NOW
LEGISLATION I THINK OF AS ANYONE
CAN HELP ME ON THIS I THINK.
A NEW LAW SAYS THAT DEATH
CERTIFICATES WILL NOW LIST.
WHETHER THE DECEDENT WAS A
VETERAN.
YES THOSE THAT TENT AND THAT
WILL BE ONE WAY FOR US TO SEE.
SOME WICKED SEX SCANDAL ALL
SUICIDES ARE ALL PEAK PTSD
RELATED OR ALL AGENT ORANGE.
TESTS AND GET A GET A BETTER
IDEA.
OF.
OF THAT.
OTHER THAN THAT I DON'T HAVE A.
I DON'T HAVE AN UPDATE THAT WAS
A DEDICATED THEIR SON ON.
WHAT YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO TRACK
THAT? AND THEN AS WELL AS ALSO
LAST YEAR YOU YOU'D MENTIONED.
.
VETERANS DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
CITIZENSHIP STATUS IS IN AND
THAT WAS ANOTHER THING THAT WE
HAD WORKED ON LAST YEAR.
WAS FOR OUR VETERANS THAT HAD
SERVED ADDED VAN NOW. HONORABLY
DISCHARGED NEED FALLEN THROUGH
THAT CRACK RIGHT.
SIR IS THERE ANYTHING YOU GUYS
ARE YEAH I WAS SO I I'M VERY I'M
FIT SINCE WE HAVE YOU HERE
MILLIONS IT IT'S GREAT I'M VERY
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO. I'M VERY
HAPPY THAT HAVE TO BE THE
SECRETARY OF THE ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT NOT JUST.
YEAH.
DEPUTY PETERSON'S PART OF IT UP
WE JUST.
FILLED OUR OUR LAST.
.
EMPTY A LEADERSHIP POSITION AT
CALVET BY LIZ PEREZ WHO MAY BE
IN THE ROOM IS NOW THE OTHER NEW
A DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR UNDER
REPRESENTED A MINORITY VETERANS.
AND THAT NOT ONLY ARE ALL THE
ETHNIC.
SUBGROUPS AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN AND THE LGBT.
BUT IT'S ALSO OF THE HOME A.
THE.
NOT DOCUMENTED.
OR.
SO IF SHE IS JUST SHOWN ME
YESTERDAY A PROPOSAL WHERE SHE
WILL START IT'S GOING TO START
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY I THINK.
WITHIN THE MONTH.
A PUBLIC MEETING WHERE ANYONE
WHO'S HAVING CITIZENSHIP ISSUES
ANY VETERAN AND THEIR FAMILY CAN
CALM AND WE WILL PROVIDE A LEGAL
ASSISTANCE AND OTHER COMMUNITY
HEALTH TO STE. START THAT
PROCESS BECOMING RIGHT AGAIN.
S. B. AGAIN FOR FURTHER PROGRESS
REPORT.
A WE WILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THANK YOU
SECRETARY ENJOYMENT OF FOR BEING
HIS AFTERNOON. I'M LOOKING AT
TRY TO KEEP IN THE LANE OF THE
HOMES.
THE.
THAT THE GRAPH THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO US WITH REGARD TO
THE NUMBER OF BEDS CAPACITY
VERSES BUDGET IT IS A FIVE
HUNDRED BAD DIFFERENCE THAT'S
THERE. AS CHRIS ABOUT
UTILIZATION SO YOU HAVE
TWO TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY.
BUDGET THAT THE WATCHER
ACTUALIZATION CENTER SO MUCH
DISCUSSION OF.
UNDER UTILIZATION BUT NOT ACTUAL
NUMBER OF BEDS DURING THESE.
SURE.
.
I'M COKIE PETERSON DEBBIE SECTOR
VETERANS HOMES THE.
OBVIOUSLY THOUGH AT ONE POINT
TIME. BEFORE I GOT HERE WE WERE
SUBJECT TO BUDGET DOES COULD
CRUNCH WHICH I THINK PUT SOME.
SOME OF THOSE CAPACITY NUMBERS
IN SUSPENSE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES IN OUR OLDER HOMES
NOT PRIMARILY.
FILL IN BARSTOW TO FILL. A EVEN
BUDGETED.
CAPACITIES FOR SAY OUR ICF FOR
OUR OR OUR OR DOMICILIARY
INDEPENDENT LIVING SO. YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY.
IT IS A CONCERN OF OURS AND WE
SEE THAT.
.
THAT ONCE WE GET.
CONFIRMATION OF A MASTER PLAN
IN TERMS OF THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT
FOR THE FUTURE GOING FORWARD.
WILL REASSESS THAT OBVIOUSLY IF
THERE'S A IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REPURPOSE THAT
SPACE.
A IT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT WE
WILL CONSIDER SENSE ESPECIALLY
SINCE WE'RE GOING DOWN THE PATH
NOW.
OF OF LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITY YOU
KNOW PHIL.
AS WELL AS BARSTOW AND THOSE
ARE THE TWO MAIN AREAS THAT THAT
WE HAVE CHALLENGES WITH CAPACITY
AND AND VERSES BUDGETED SO.
AGAIN THAT THERE WAS A REASON
FOR IT AND THEN THERE'S JUST NO
DEMAND WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF
THOSE SO WHAT WILL WILL GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THAT WE CONTINUED
LOOK AT THAT SO YOU KNOW I
FIGURE YOU CAN GO TO. NOW NOT
NOT TODAY BUT I CAN GET YOU AN
ANSWER YEAH I'D BE CURIOUS WITH
THE DELTA IS ON THAT JUST
BECAUSE ACTUALLY IF THERE'S
CAPACITY YOU KNOW I'D LOVE TO
SEE IT THERE BUT NOW YOU KNOW
BUT I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW I'M
I'M DOWN A HUNDRED. AND TWENTY
TWO DOMICILIARY IN YOUNTVILLE
OKAY.
TWENTY SEVEN ICF AND THAT'S
JUST ON BUDGET NUMBERS.
IT'S ALREADY OFF THE TOP OF OUR
BUDGET NUMBERS AND WELL BELOW
OUR BUDGET NUMBERS WHICH PUTS US
WELL BELOW OUR CAPACITY FOR.
AND THAT'S WHAT RANDY GET AT
YEAH SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW WHAT YOU WHAT WE BUILT A
WHAT WE'VE GIVEN YOU MONEY FOR.
WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY USING
SCISSORS TWENTY DISCUSSION ABOUT
NOT SIZE OF OUR QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY AND WILL CERTAINLY
TAKE THAT CONSIDERATION AND
THEN?
?
WHAT WOULD BE THE CALL I MEAN?
AGAIN I KNOWLEDGE IS A MASTER
PLAN IS HOLDING GOING ON
PETROLEUM ARMS AROUND WHAT A I
THINK THERE IS THE STATUS OF
THEIR SUMMER MENTIONED ABOUT
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
PER BED. IS THAT RIGHT SO IS
ABOUT MY WOULD SIT I WOULD
SUSPECT THAT SOMEWHAT SENSITIVE
TO THE LEVEL OF SKILL. THAT'S
NEEDED YOU KNOW THAT INDEPENDENT
LIVING ISN'T SEVENTY ONE GRAN
ARE CERTAINLY HOPE IT IS SO SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS THERE'S THERE'S
THERE'S COSTS.
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE BASED ON
THE LEVEL OF CARE IN YOUR MORE
INDEPENDENT LEVELS CARE NOT AS
EXPENSIVE. AND YOUR HIGHER
LEVELS OF CARE MORE EXPENSIVE SO
ON READING ARE RC A FEE LEVEL OF
CARES ABOUT A. HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE DOLLARS A DAY IN THE
SKILLED NURSING IN REDDING IS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY AND YOU CALCULATE
THAT OUT. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT IT
COST TO BE AN RC A FEW WHAT
ACOSTA BE INNOCENT HAVE. NOW THE
RESIDENTS AS YOU KNOW BASED ON
ON ON OUR. VETERANS KOBE SOME
STATUTE ARE ARE REQUIRED PAPER
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR INCOME BASED
UPON THE LEVEL OF CARE.
THEY'RE ALSO OFFSET WITH PER
DIEM FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND THAT ESSENTIALLY GETS US TO
A POINT WHERE THERE'S THERE'S A
DELTA.
WHERE THE TAXPAYERS?
HAVE.
GRACIOUSLY.
MADE UP THE DIFFERENCE
OBVIOUSLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS.
OR TRY TO BE VERY FISCALLY
PRUDENT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS WERE LOOKING.
YOU KNOW THIS LAST BUDGET CYCLE
WE INTRODUCED THE REQUIREMENT TO
HAVE INSURANCE.
WILL HELP TO FOR COSTS OF CARE.
WERE ALSO IT WE INSERTED THE AT
THE ADMISSIONS FOCUS ON THE ONES
THAT HAVE SERVED THE MOUSE ARE
GIVEN THE MOST SEVENTY
PERCENTERS THEY GET ENHANCE PER
DIEM OF ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY SO YOU CAN SEE.
THE MORE SEVENTY PERCENTERS WE
HAVE. A FOUR HUNDRED DOLLAR
DAYBED.
THE BETTER OFF WE'LL BE SURE.
AND OF COURSE WHERE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO STANDARD
STANDARDIZE ACROSS ALL OF THE
HOMES ARE IN CAPTURE MEDICARE
DOLLARS FOR PARTY PARTY PARTY.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE IN IN ENSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR ELIGIBLE FOLKS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAID AND.
IN ATTENDANCE.
THAT WE GET THEM ENROLLED AND I
THINK A COMBINATION OF ALL THOSE
EFFORTS WILL GIVE US MUCH CLOSER
TO WHAT THE SECRETARY WAS SAYING
ONE IT SAID. SENATE COVERING ONE
THIRD MAYBE WE CAN GET A LITTLE
OVER HALF. A SOME STATES LIKE TO
DO JUST SEVENTY PERCENT OR SOME
STATES LIKE TO DO JESS MEDICAID
SOME STATES LIKE TO MAKE IT PAY
WHAT IT COSTS AND SO IT'S A
DISCUSSION THAT CERTAINLY WE ARE
WELL AWARE OF AND. WE KEEP
LOOKING AT WELL AS WHAT TO
RESPOND IN KNOWING WHAT YOUR
ACTUAL UTILIZATION.
PASSED THE BUDGET BUT ACCOUNT
FOR UTILIZATION WATCHER AT JUST
GENERAL I REALIZE THAT
FLUCTUATES PIE BY THE HOUR
FRANKLY. FIRMS ARE ALSO
UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT WHAT IS IT FROM A BUDGET
PASSING ME WHAT IF WHAT WOULD IT
TAKE TO FULLY COME UTILIZE YOUR
CAPACITY RIGHT I REALIZE IT'S
NOT REALLY A MARK CONCERN RIGHT
NOW? BUT AS WE TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW HAS LEGISLATORS
UNDERSTANDING OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES UP FUND YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
TO GET YOU TO FOR. A TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FIFTY.
I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF OF YOU KNOW
MAKING. BALLOTS ARE CASH FLOW OR
WHAT HAVE YOU AND I LOVED AT THE
POLICY DISCUSSION PROBABLY AT A
LATER DATE AFTER THE MASTER PLAN
UNDERSTAND IT DO WE WANT TO BE A
SEVENTY PERCENT ARE ONLY STATE
OR DO WE WANT TO GO A DIFFERENT
WAY. I'M I GUESS THAT CONCERNED
I HAD AFTER REVIEWING THESE
MATERIALS LAST NIGHT WAS IT
THERE ARE UNOCCUPIED BEDS AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT CHILDRESS IS A
REALLY HAVE THIS PROBLEM RIGHT
AND WHERE WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT WE
HAVE THAT FABULOUS FACILITY I IN
IN MY IN MANY NUYS NECK OF THE.
WOODS
ASIDE TO JONATHAN'S ANTES NECK
OF THE WOODS ARMED. BUT IT I
REALIZE THAT THAT'S NOT THE SAID
THE CASE IN OTHER PLACES BUT.
A CERTAIN EXPLAINED ANY TAXPAYER
THAT WE HAVE ON UTILIZED ASSETS.
IS DIFFICULT TO IS A DIFFICULT
MESSAGE TO SHARE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
GOOD AND REAL REASONS WHY THAT'S
THE CASE BUT WE NEED TO FLIP
THAT AROUND.
REALLY IN LIGHT OF HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS.
YOU KNOW I I UNDERSTAND SAME
SECRETARY ABOUT THAT THERE ARE
BEDS AVAILABLE I RECOGNIZE OF
THE FROM MOTIVATED VETERANS
THEY'D THAT'S PROBABLY THE CASE.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT WE HAVE
PLENTY TO GO I'M SHELTERED OF
EVERY NIGHT AND I'LL Y. CAN
REPRESENT THAT EVERY A
HOMOSEXUAL AND MOVED BARSTOW.
I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT THEY CAN GET THEIR OR
THEY'D BE UTILIZED I READ THE
MATERIALS UNDERSTAND THAT COMES
A HIGHER LEVEL OF SKILL PUBLICLY
MORE MONEY. ON BUT I'D LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER IS WHAT IT
IS SIR I'M SORRY YET KNOW IT SON
I'M BE MORE TALK ABOUT IF YOU
WANT TO SAY SOMETHING ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT THEY WERE PROUD
TO SAY IS THAT THAT WE WENT BACK
AND WE LOOK. AT THE NUMBERS WE
THE I BELIEVE IT WAS THIRTY
PERCENT OF LAST YEAR'S
ADMISSIONS WHERE WERE HOMELESS
VETERANS ACROSS ALL OF OUR
VETERANS HOMES.
AND AS YOU KNOW WITH THE TEACH
PEOPLE WOMAN WEST LA THAT'S NO
LONGER OPERATING BUT WE WE GO
OUT OF OUR WAY WE WE WERE
CONSTANTLY GETTING PHONE CALLS
FROM FOLKS THAT SAY HEY WE HAVE
A VET DO YOU HAVE A PLACE FOR
THEM AND. TYPICALLY ARE OPENINGS
RIGHT NOW OUR BARSTOW AND AND I
AND SOMETIMES.
SOMETIMES YOUNTVILLE MOSTLY
BARSTOW CHULA VISTA FOR SOME
REASON IS IS CORNERED THE MARKET
ON DOM NOT SO THERE'S NEVER BEDS
AVAILABLE THERE BUT. WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT THOSE NUMBERS
WILL GO DOWN IN THERE MAYBE.
A NEED TO REPURPOSE ALSO TAUGHT
FOR HOMELESS WILL CERTAINLY TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT PASSING TERMS OF
BIHAC PARA ON THIS IS MY SOME OF
MY PAST LIFE.
LIKE I'VE ONLY BEEN TO THREE OF
THE VETERANS ON I MEAN ALL OF
THEM MY SUSPICION IS THAT YOU
COULD WORK CLOSELY WITH SOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
TO.
YIELD UNITS.
AND A REVENUE STREAM QUITE
FRANKLY I'M AND YOU KNOW WHY I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FROM OF MY
COLLEAGUE REPRESENTS NAPA
IMAGINE THOSE CULTURAL AMENITIES
THAT YOU MENTIONED ARE VERY
POINT THEIR CONSTITUENTS. THINK
YOU'RE HARD PRESSED TO MAKE THE
CASE THAT THOSE ARE SOMEHOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE CARE OF OUR
VETERANS I'M. AND SO A KNOWING
THAT LAND IS OFTEN THE BIGGEST
DRIVER OF.
WHETHER OUR PROJECT AND WORK OR
NOT WORK THE EXTENT THAT YOU CAN
BE HAVE GOOD NEIGHBORS I REALIZE
ARE NOT COMPLETELY BUILT AND IS
ANOTHER PART IT'S AVAILABLE AT
RITUALISTIC.
.
YOU KNOW MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL HOUSING.
IN THE IN THE MARKET SEGMENTS
THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER
SUBSCRIBE SO I'M I JUST HOPE
THAT THAT SOME SECURITY TEND TO
DO THAT THE BEING IS ON JUNE OR
ELSE POSSIBLE. A TO GET TO THE.
TO THE POINT THAT WITH FULL
LEGALIZATION AYE THAT YOU LIKE
WE CAN ASK US FOR MORE MONEY AND
AND YOU COULD USE IT.
AND.
THAT WHEN NATURALLY EVERY
VETERAN WHO NEEDS IT GETS THE
SERVICE AND CERTAINLY THAT NO
VETERAN EVER GOES HOMELESS OF.
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT'S
EFFORTS STATE A SECRETARY AND UP
FOR YOU AND YOUR TEAM.
AND CERTAINLY HAVE A PARTNER
HERE DO WHATEVER WE CAN ATTEND.
HELP YOU AS YOU GOT THIS MASTER
PLAN PROCESS
THANK YOU THINK AMERICA'S
FAVORITE AND AND AND I I MAYBE
YOU CAN JUST BRIEFLY MENTION
WHAT HAPPENED AND INVENTOR OF
THE.
LAND RIGHT NEXT TO THE HOME WAS
ACTUALLY GIVEN BACK TO THE CITY
BLOOM CITY HAS AN RFP OUT TO
DEVELOP OF VETERANS HOUSING SO
THAT IS HAPPENING AT SOME OF THE
OTHER HOMES SO. THEY GIVE UP THE
BUT THE ASSET. WELL THE CITY WAS
GOING TO GET IT BACK IN THE
MONEY TWENTY ONE A IF WE DID NOT
BUILD OR EXPAND THE PRESENT TO
RC A FEE OF SIXTY BEDS THERE.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THE LAND WOULD
HAVE REVERTED BUT.
IT WOULD WE DECIDED WE WEREN'T
GOING TO SO WHY SHOULD WE SETTLE
AND WHEN THEY.
A VERY WHAT I PARTICULARLY
WANTED TO START BUILDING A
VETERAN CENTRIC.
HOUSING PROJECT OUT NOW SO
BEFORE THAT PROP FORTY ONE FUND
RAN OUT.
WE WORK TOGETHER TO GET THE
MONEY BACK TO THE CITY AND AND.
I WAS ONE OF THEIR TOP
PRIORITIES I I'M NOT SURE HOW
MANY OF VETERANS ARE GOING TO BE
HOUSE THERE BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
HAS HAPPENED AT OTHER HOMES
WITH.
THAT HAVE EXCESSIVE UP PROPERTY
SO STILL FURTHERING VETERANS
NEEDS.
BUT YOU'LL GET THE ACID ON THE
BOOKS AT BECAUSE I LIKE WAS OURS
TO BE ENDLESSLY YEAH I'M JUST
GONNA COME IN MY NAME ST GERARD
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY ON
THE TWO PROPOSALS THAT.
VENTURA HAS PUT FORWARD ARE
BEING ACT.
EVALUATED TOMORROW AND I
BELIEVE THE NUMBERS ARE ONE TO
TWO HUNDRED.
ONE PROPOSAL IS A HUNDRED THE
OTHERS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED.
FOR LOW INCOME.
VETERAN HOUSING AND IT JUST
RIGHT BEHIND THE FACILITY SO.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT IT IS IS IN LINE
WITH OUR MISSION. AND WE WE ARE
PARTICIPATORY AND AND WHAT THAT
END RESULT WILL BE.
GREAT.
A ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND.
MR SECRETARY IN YOUR STAFF I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE AYE AYE
I'VE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
FOUR YEARS AND.
.
SINCE YOU'RE NEW MANAGEMENT TEAM
IS COMING I'VE SEEN A REMARKABLE
DIFFERENCE.
IN.
SUSTAINING.
THE.
GOOD LIFE OF A VETERAN AND EVE
WHEN YOU'VE MADE. MAKE SOME
BOUNDS.
I TOWARDS THAT END AND I WILL
HAVE TO TELL YOU MEN CHAIR THAT.
THE SECTARIAN I HAD. A
DISCUSSION ABOUT A NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIAN VETERANS.
AND THIS MAN WENT TO
RESERVATIONS TRYING TO FIND OUT
HOW WE CAN BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
SO HE CAN YOU GIVE HIM A PROBLEM
HE DOES GO OUT AND PLAY.
TRIED BROUGHT HOME PROVIDE THE
SOLUTION.
SO BUT YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE
THIS LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
CAME THROUGH IN AND.
.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE ACUTE
SHORTCOMINGS THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION ON
IT'S A REPORTS ON THE HOMES?
AB.
WELL I I I THINK IT.
I'M GOING TO PUT THAT QUESTION
WHAT SHORTCOMINGS TO THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION BREAKPOINT TO
RATHER THAN. THE COMMISSION
SHORTCOMINGS THAT AFFECTS AYE
YEAH YEAH. YEAH THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN BUT.
AND WHAT WE WANNA DAY IDENTIFY
THAT TODAY YEAH I. THINK YEAH.
WHAT ARE FIRST OF ALL I THINK
THEY?
THEY ENCOURAGED US TO OF.
TO LOOK AT.
SERIOUSLY LOOK AT PARTNERSHIPS
IN THE ARM PRIVATE WORLD IN THE
NONPROFIT WORLD TO HELP US SO WE
DON'T HAVE EXPERTISE IN THAT.
THING THAT THEY REALIZE THAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
HOMELESS WAS.
ANTIQUATED AND.
THE LIVERY OF MEDICAL CARE WAS
NOT EFFICIENT THERE IN ALMOST
HELPED POINT THE DIRECTION
TOWARD A NEW FACILITY FOR ME.
ARM.
AND.
.
SUPPORTING THE
THE CONCEPT OF.
PERIODICALLY STUDYING EVERY HOME
WHICH IS WHAT THIS LEGISLATION
ON THE HOME SPECIFIC MASTER PLAN
IS GOING TO DO.
AND I THINK ALSO.
.
NOT THE.
IT'S SHORT ALL OF THEIR FINDINGS
WERE THINGS THAT WE EITHER
SUSPECTED OR HAD ALREADY STARTED
DUBBED WORKING ON AND WERE
ALMOST RELIEF TO BUT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE GOING
TO CHANGE. ARM IN FIVE YEARS.
EVERY WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN WILL
BE A HUNDRED YEARS OR OLDER.
IN TEN YEARS EVERY KOREAN WHERE
THAT WILL BE NINETY YEARS OLD OR
OLDER.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THE
NUMBER OF VETERANS THAT ARE THEN
GOING TO START COMING JUST TEN
YEARS FROM NOW. BY THIS MAN
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF VIETNAM
VETERANS BUT I THINK AT THE SAME
TIME MEDICAL SCIENCE.
WHICH I FOLLOW IT MAY BE MORE
CLOSELY THAN ANYONE ELSE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE KINDS OF
INJURIES THAT THE YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN ARE SO STAYING IN THE IRAQ
WAR I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO WAIVE SIMULTANEOUSLY COMING
AT US.
BECAUSE THE YOUNG FOLKS ARE
SUSTAINING BRAIN INJURIES.
DRAMATIC.
ENCEPHALITIS THAT THESE AND UP
BUT FORGET THE MENTAL HEALTH AT
THE.
POSTER MATIC STRESS JUST THE
ORGANIC INJURIES ARE GOING TO
PRESENT WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND TO OUTRIGHT DEMENTIA
IN NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE NOT
ANTICIPATED.
.
SO IT IT ASKING US TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S COMING. WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT A WAY FOR THAT IS.
IT'S VERY SCARY TO BEHOLD.
I DON'T KNOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR ANY STATE IS GOING
TO PREPARED BE PREPARD TO DO.
THE BEST JOB IT WISHED IT COULD
DO.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIND OUT
GIVEN THE RESOURCES WE HAVE WHAT
IS THE BEST WE CAN DO IT ALL.
TO. HIM BASED ON THAT WE HAD A
MASTER PLAN I GUESS THAT YOU HAD
PUBLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND. ARE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
AND SO IT'S SIX YEARS OLD.
TIMES OF CHANGED.
SO WHAT OF THAT MASTER PLAN OR
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO USE IF AT
ALL.
AND WHILE. MOST OF WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT.
.
WHO DO YOU HAVE WORKING ON IT
NOW?
AND DO THEY HAVE THE SKILL SET
TO TO CONTINUE. AND ADAPT TO THE
LITTLE OVER PLANS THAT.
ASSISTANT WITH A DEPUTY A GERARD
HERE I THINK COMMISSION PEPTO
MISTER PLANNING TO THOUSAND
TWELVE SO WANTED TO TAKE
WHATEVER START.
SO THE ORIGINAL MASTER PLAN WAS
CREATED FOR A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT REASONS.
IT WAS CREATED TO TAKE ALL OF A
LONGER. TERM LOOK AT WHAT WE
MIGHT DO WITH THE PROPERTY
THERE'S A PROCESS CALLED THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
PLAN WITHIN THE STATE BUDGET
CYCLE AND. WHAT WE WERE DOING AT
THE TIME WORK JUST BANDAID
APPROACHES TO SIMPLE
INFRASTRUCTURE DID MAINTENANCE
A?
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE HOME WE
NEEDED A BROADER.
VIEW OF THINGS AND SO WHAT WE
DID WAS WE WENT OUT AND HIRED A.
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM THAT HAD
LONG TERM CARE.
EXPERTISE
AND TOOK A LOOK AT THE BUILDING
STRUCTURE I WE HIRED FOLKS FROM.
GENERAL SERVICES IN THE REAL
ESTATE WORLD TECH.
TO HELP US COME UP WITH SOME
CONCEPTUAL IDEAS SO THAT. WE HAD
SOMETHING TO.
TO REFER BACK TO WHEN IT CAME TO
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY PROCESS.
SNIFFED BUILDING.
COINCIDENTALLY.
WAS THE HIGHEST PRIORITY BASED
ON THE CONDITIONS OF HOLDER
MEANT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
ELEVEN.
AND SO IT'S NOT. UNREASONABLE TO
THINK THAT TODAY WE HAVE THE
SAME PROBLEM WE'VE BEEN.
PUTTING MONEY INTO IT.
HAND OVER FIST AND WHILE WE'RE
STAYING UP WATER THE THE YOU
KNOW THAT THE STANDARD OF. CARE
FOR.
A ROOM IS NOT ADEQUATE.
SO THERE WERE A VARIETY OF OF
REASONS OF WHY WE DID THAT.
THERE SOME CONCEPTUAL IDEAS
ABOUT USING PUBLIC.
ENTITIES TO HELP US WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT BASED ON THE FACT
THAT THE STATE BUDGET PROCESSES
IS IS CUMBERSOME INCIDENTS.
THERE'S EVALUATION OF LEASES
AND SO FORTH WHAT WE'VE DONE
SINCE THAT TIME IS.
IMPLEMENTED.
AS MANY OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THE AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE
FOR THE STATE'S AUTHORITY ALLOWS
SO WE'VE TALKED WE'VE MADE FOR.
EFFORTS IN EIGHTY A WE'VE.
ADDRESSED.
FAIR MARKET VALUE WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
WE'VE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
ADJACENCY. BUILDING.
WE'VE.
.
DEVELOPED.
THAT REACHED OUT.
TO THE TOWN TO SEE HOW WE CAN.
RESOLVER REDUCE COSTS IN JUST A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS
UP WE CONTINUE TO USE.
THE THE EXISTING MASTER PLAN
FOR YOUNTVILLE.
.
AND AND PULL FROM IT WHAT IS
RELEVANT.
WHAT IS A ACCOMPLISH?
MOBILE. AND WE CONTINUE TO TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THE.
RESEARCH ARE THEY THE MASTER
PLANNING FOR THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
THAT THAT.
DOCUMENT FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WILL BE INCORPORATED INTO
THE OTHER PIECES OF INFORMATION
AND AND UTILIZED.
FOR THE OVERALL SYSTEM.
SO.
THAT.
THAT'S ALL I RESPOND TO THAT.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE ONE HAVING
MORE QUESTIONS SO YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE PER DIEM IN YOU MEDI
CAL MEDICARE AND. AND.
.
AND CAL THAT.
WHERE THE PERSON IS IT
PERCENTAGES OF EACH?
SO WE KNOW WHAT.
WITH SILO WHO I WAS SO RIGHT NOW
OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF OF
REVENUES VIS A PER DIEM.
EIGHT ATTENDANCE IS ABOUT THREE
PERCENT ARMY PRETTY ABOUT SIXTY
THREE PERCENT.
EIGHT ATTENDANCE IS THREE
PERCENT ORG OR CURRENTLY
ESTIMATING A MEDI CAL AROUND
NINE PERCENT.
MEDICARE AGAIN AB IS AROUND SIX
PERCENT.
AND IN FEES DE INSURANCE OTHER
THINGS ARE ARE AROUND THE.
THE.
ONE PERCENT SO.
I I THINK THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
AGAIN YOU HAVE TO BE QUALIFIED
FOR MEDIC MEDIC CAO.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING THOSE WERE
BEING VERY ACTIVE IN THOSE IN
THOSE SEARCHES.
.
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT WERE
JUST AGAIN BEEN A LITTLE BUSY
WITH FOCUSING ON THE FIVE OTHER
HOMES BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN
AREA THAT WE THINK WE CAN TOUCH
THAT WE THINK WE CAN.
WE CAN EXPLORE GET A GREAT DEAL
OF OF OF OF REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR FOR MEDI CAL RESIDENTS THAT
ARE QUALIFIED.
WHAT'S THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE TO.
WE WOULD GO BELOW THAT TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD SO.
THAT WE DO WE DO KNOW SOME
STATES DO THAT IN THE FORMER
MEDICAID IN THAT'S ALL THEY'RE
ABLE TO GET AS CLOSE TO REVENUE
NEUTRAL AS POSSIBLE WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE LOOK DOWN THAT PATH.
ISSUES ELIGIBLE.
JUST ON I KNOW I MEAN WE TALK
ABOUT BARSTOW BEFORE AND IF AT
ALL HARD TIME WITH THE OCCUPANCY
THERE AND AND PEOPLE EVEN WANT
TO WORK THERE.
WHEN YOU SAY WHEN.
AND ACTUALLY YOU KNOW CUT FISH
OR CUT BAIT.
I.
THAT MAY BE THE IMPLICIT ARM.
OUR THAT'S IMPLIED IN.
DEVELOPING MASTER PLANS FOR EACH
OF THE HOMES.
SO WE PROBABLY WILL HAVE AN
ANSWER ON OUR ALL OF OUR HOMES
THE RIGHT SIZE DELIVERING THE
RIGHT LEVEL OF CARE AND IN THE
RIGHT PLACE.
IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS IF NOT
BEFORE.
I DID JUST THAT I'M NOT SURE IF
OF THE ONE OTHER QUESTION WAS
ANSWERED ABOUT THE RESOURCES
THAT OR WHO WHO IS IT THAT YOU
HAVE WORKING ON THAT MASTER PLAN
THE RESOURCES HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT.
IT IS DONE ON TIME AND IS.
HIGH QUALITY OF THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT DOCUMENT FOR THE HOMES
AND SO I WASN'T SURE IF I HEARD.
I HEARD. THAT.
RIGHT A DUCK IN THE I'M SORRY
MA'AM ARE YOU TALKING THE MASTER
PLAN FOR YOU NOW.
THE OVERALL MASTER PLAN MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S.
IT HAS.
.
THAT ANSWERS ALL OUR QUESTIONS
IN A TIMELY MANNER AND DO THOSE
HIGH QUALITY HAVE WHO DO WE HAD
DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES
BEING SPENT ON MAKING SURE.
THAT.
WE END UP. WITH A GOOD PRODUCT.
ON JULY TWENTY NINETEEN AND
DELIGHT NINETEEN YES MA'AM AS
THE SECRETARY MENTIONED IS IN IS
IN HIS OPENING REMARKS WE WE'VE
HIRED A. AN AMAZING.
TALENTED INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS.
.
THAT IS IMPRESSED US.
IT WITH HER.
APPRECIATION OF THE OF THE ASK.
WITH THE PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE.
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE AUTHORIZED TO
TO INDIVIDUALS TO DO THIS AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF OF THE
HIGHER IN THE SECOND PERSON.
NOW WE FEEL COMFORTABLE AT THIS
STAGE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE.
OVERSIGHT ON A REGULAR BASIS.
ALONG THE WAY IF WE FEEL LIKE
THAT THAT THAT. THERE'S A ISSUE
WITH THIS WILL LET LET EVERYBODY
KNOW BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW IF
YOU REALLY ENCOURAGE WITH WHO WE
GOT SOMEBODY THAT UNDERSTANDS
THIS THE SORT OF A RESEARCH.
AND THAT WILL BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
WHAT WE'VE MASTERED TWO AWE ON
TIME AND WANTED TO SAY THE
SECOND PERSON IS COMING ON BOARD
HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED THAT WE HAVE
HIRED WE HAD WERE IN THE HIRING
PROCESS NOW.
REVIEWING.
INDIVIDUALS.
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S AN AGP EIGHT
POSITION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL ROCA.
I AM.
RECENTLY BECAME THE VICE CHAIR
ASSISTING OUR CHAIR.
AND I JUST WANTED TO LET. YOU
KNOW MISTER SECRETARY YOUR
ASSISTANT SECRETARIES.
THAT DUMB.
I BEEN WORKING ON WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
THIS IS ONLY THE TIP OF YOUR
ICEBERG.
AND.
.
I. MAKE A VOWED TO YOU AND TO
OUR CHAIR.
THAT I WILL WORK DILIGENTLY AND
VERY HARD.
AND I WILL BE YOUR WORKER BEE TO
THE GREATEST OF MY. ABILITY.
I FIND IT IRONIC.
YEAH FULLY VETTED COULD SAY IT
THIS WAY I FIND IT IRONIC THAT
I'M THE. LAST CURRENTLY SERVING
VIETNAM VETERAN IN THE WHOLE
LEGISLATURE.
AND SO DO MY SISTERS AND
BROTHERS.
I'LL BE WORKING.
I'LL BE WORKING FOR YOU.
WITH THAT SAID THOUGH.
WE HAVE MAJOR SYSTEMIC AND
BUSINESS MODEL.
CHANGES AND.
TWEAKS THAT WE HAVE TO DO.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
AND WHAT I. BASE THAT UPON IS
NOT JUST A SEVENTY PERCENT AND
THE HARD MONEY.
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
BUT WE ALSO.
WILL BE WORKING TO NOT
COMPROMISING THE CARE.
IN THE LOVE.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT ME YOU CAN'T
PUT LOVE INTO A SPREADSHEET.
OKAY BECAUSE FROM PEOPLE.
SO WE WANNA KEEP THAT PART OF
THAT AS WELL.
THE DIFFERENT CHANGES.
MANY WILL BE GOOD.
AND.
HERE'S MY MASTER PLAN IN MY HEAD
JUST SO YOU GENTLEMEN KNOW.
RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT THESE.
TORRANCE AND WAVES OF VETERANS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE NEEDING
HELP.
WE ALSO HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT.
THAT THE WAR ON TERROR.
IS NEVER ENDING.
WE WILL HAVE NEW WARS.
WE MAY HAVE A NEW GENERATION OF
KOREAN WAR VETERANS WE DON'T
KNOW IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS WORLD
RIGHT NOW.
SO.
I'M FIGURING.
THAT.
WE MAKE OUR BEST MASTER PLAN.
AND THEN YOU FIGURED THAT AS
SOON AS WE EXECUTED AND REALLY
GET GO ON GONNA CHANGE
COMPLETELY.
AND THAT'S IS GONNA BE THE
NATURE OF THE BEAST THAT WE
FACE.
SO GOD BLESS YOU A GOOD IDEA.
WORK IT.
A.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR OF I I JUST
HAVE THE AYE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WE NEED TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PANEL WITHOUT A LOT OF AND
QUESTIONS HERE BUT I I'D DO JUST
WANTED I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY AT.
GOT PHIL AT THE ON THAT
PROPERTY AND SO HOPEFULLY. YOU
DO OUT SOMEBODY VERY CREATIVE
THAT'S GOING TO GET SOME GOOD
SOLUTIONS THERE. BUT I WANT TO
GO BACK TO I THINK IT WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COPIER THAT
BROUGHT UP THE.
.
UNFAVORABLE LEASES WAS THAT YOU
THAT BROUGHT THOSE UP. AND I
JUST LIKE HOW DID THOSE GET
APPROVED AND.
GOING FORWARD.
DOES THERE NEED TO BE OF MORE
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
REALLY YOU WERE THERE.
BUT.
WE WERE THERE THANK YOU SIR.
SO THE SO THE LEASES THAT ARE
THAT THAT ARE IN PLAY THAT ARE.
.
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY GENERAL
SERVICES ARE.
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THE.
BEST VALUE AT THE TIME.
THAN THE CIRCUMSTANCE.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT.
FAIR MARKET VALUE IS WHAT THE.
.
THE LAW WOULD REQUIRE. A WE
ALWAYS START OUT FROM THAT POINT
FORWARD AND WE TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT FAIR MARKET VALUE IS FOR
THE SPACE WE ALSO INCLUDES.
UTILITIES AND SO FORTH.
GENERALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS IS
THAT. ARE ALONG THE PROCESS.
WE SOMETIMES FROM.
.
ARE GREETED WITH EXTERNAL
INFLUENCE THAT ALLOWS US OR.
OBLIGATES US TO.
ADJUST ACCORDINGLY.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY SET THESE
THE RATES ARE OURSELVES WE DO A
COLLABORATIVE LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND PERHAPS.
THE.
THE OCCUPANT.
AND SO.
.
THAT THAT SPEAKS AGAINST TO THE
CURRENT STATUS THEY THEY THE
LEASES ARE APPROPRIATE AT THE
TIME THEY WERE IMPLEMENTED.
WE TRY TO IMPLEMENT FIVE YEAR.
DURATION TERMS
SO THAT WHEN THE.
.
POLICE HAS EXPIRED OR
APPROACHING WE CAN REVISIT THE.
FAIR MARKET VALUE AND GO
THROUGH THAT SAME PROCESS AGAIN
THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE VERY
VERY OLD.
THAT BEEN ESTABLISHED THEY WERE
NOT ESTABLISHED PERHAPS BY OUR
INITIATION BUT PERHAPS BY AN
EXTERNAL ENTITY OR A.
LEGISLATIVE LEADER AND WHAT
HAVE YOU AWARE THOSE LEASES ARE
FAIRLY ROCK SOLID.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY CAN'T BE
REVISITED BUT THE.
I GUESS LIKE I REFER BACK TO
THE TERM. AND THE VALUE AT THE
TIME.
REPRESENTS THE CIRCUMSTANCE
SO WE HAVE A COUPLE THAT ARE
COMING UP.
THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT WE ARE
IN PROCESS WITH AND WE WILL
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE SAME.
ROUTE WHERE WE WILL PURSUE FAIR
MARKET VALUE AND WE'LL SEE WHERE
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS INCOME.
COME TO A CONCLUSION AS TO
WHAT'S FAIR INVEST FOR FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED.
SOMETIMES.
HAVING.
THE OCCUPANTS WITHIN OUR
BUILDINGS.
VACANT BUILDINGS JUST KEEP THEM
OPERATIONAL ON THAT ACTUALLY IS
A PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE TYPE
OF THING AS WELL SO SOMETIMES WE
LOOK AT IT THAT WAY ITSELF AS
WELL.
SO YOU WOULD SAY THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT YOU'RE
YOU'RE SAYING THESE WERE FAIR AT
THE TIME THAT THEY WERE.
PUT INTO PLACE OR THAT THERE
DOESN'T REALLY NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT.
THEY HAD. DONE WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS THEY REPRESENT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE DAY
SOMETIMES THE THE THE THE BUDGET
ENVIRONMENT SHIFTS AND OBLIGATE
AND THERE'S MORE INFLUENCE THAT
WE HAVE TO PERHAPS CECA A HIGHER
LEVEL OF REVENUE SOMETIMES THE
EXTERNAL PRESSURE SHIPS IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION. TO WHERE
PERHAPS.
THOUGH LEASE SEE.
OCCUPIES THAT SPACE BECAUSE
IT'S MORE IN LINE WITH OUR OUR
MISSION AND VISION SO IT SORT OF
DEPENDS
WHETHER THEY. WERE WELL AWARE.
OF OF WHAT THOSE.
WITH THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE.
.
AS FAR AS ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT.
I THINK GENERAL SERVICES
PROVIDES
RE OF.
VERY GOOD OVERSIGHT AS TO WHAT
THE EXPECTATION OF LEASES ARE
AND HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE.
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL.
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A VERY INFORMATIVE AND.
MAKE SURE TO LET US KNOW HOW
YOU ARE. PROGRESSING ON THE.
ON THE MASTER PLAN AND AGAIN.
VICE JUST THE BIG DIFFERENCE
WITH YOUR CHANGE IN LEADERSHIP
AND AND.
WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF NO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMPLIMENTS THINKING FAVOR MUCH.
ALL RIGHT AND.
WE HAVE OUR SECOND PANEL.
FROM THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
.
THE HONORABLE PEDRO NAVA.
WHO IS THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION ALSO
JACQUELYN?
BORROWS ROSSIO AND.
BURT.
MCCHESNEY.
AND LIKE TO SAY OF WELCOME TO
ALL THREE OF YOU AND AND.
ESPECIALLY TWO CHAIRMEN OF THE.
.
YOU GUYS DID. EXTRAORDINARY JOB
ON THE REPORT WE REALLY
APPRECIATES BECAUSE THE AMOUNT
OF TIME AND EFFORT THAT WENT
INTO IT. AS YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF
YOUR SUGGESTIONS WERE. PUT INTO
OF BILLS LAST YEAR.
TO START TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THE CHANGES THAT YOU SUGGESTED
SO. FOR VERY ANXIOUS TO HEAR
FROM YOU ABOUT AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR.
.
THE INVITATION I AM A PEDRO
NOVEL FORMER LEGISLATOR NOW. I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF SERVING AS
A CHAIR OF LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
AND I BUT I DO HAVE TO MENTION
THAT.
NOW AFTER HEARING SECRETARY
EMBASSY ANI.
.
MAKE REMARKS IN LATIN.
I'M JUST FILL THAT OVERPOWERED
BECAUSE. I I WAS.
I WAS SO EXCITED MY LAST MOVIE
WAS JUMANJI AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
TERRIFIC SO.
BUT I WANT TO THANK BOB OF THE
CHAIR. AND VICE CHAIR IN
MEMBERS.
.
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND FOR.
THEIR SUPPORT AND OF THEIR
COMMITMENT.
TO WORKING ON OF THESE VETERANS
ISSUES.
AND.
IT WAS UP SOMETHING THAT ALL OF
US AT THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
REALLY EMBRACED
I BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT QUITE FRANKLY THE FREEDOMS
THAT WE ENJOY.
AND OUR PROSPERITY
IS DUE IN NO SMALL PART
TO THE SACRIFICES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE BY THE MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO PUT THEMSELVES IN HARM'S
WAY EVERY DAY?
FOR FOR.
AND
TO THEM I WANTED THE EXTEND A
SPECIAL
THANK YOUS WELL.
I'M.
I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR.
THAT THE SECRETARY BOSSY ANI
THAT HAS APPROACHED HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES A WITH A A.
BUT THE PASSION.
A BUT ALSO WITH A SENSE OF WHAT
IS PRACTICAL.
BOB AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
AND THAT THAT YOU SEE AND HOW
THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
RESPONDING TO VARIOUS. BUT
CHALLENGES.
BOB YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE STATE
OPERATE VETERANS HOME.
THAT WE HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST
SYSTEMS IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT THE BULB BUDGET IS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
SIXTY PERCENT OF THAT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE COMES FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
A SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ABOUT PRICE A PER BED PER YEAR
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY MORE THAN THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND.
ONCE YOU TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THE REIMBURSEMENTS IN THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT COME FROM
OTHER SOURCES.
SO IT'S A ONE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR A COST
PER BED AND THE LEGISLATURE UP
THE IS RIGHT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT COST AND TO.
HOW THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
MAYBE THERE ARE BETTER AND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO GO ABOUT
CARING FOR VETERANS IN OUR
STATE?
BOB.
YOU'VE GOT ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THEM ARE FIFTY FIVE OR OLDER UP
BUT THE BEDS AVAILABLE ARE THERE
FOR A LESS THAN ONE PERCENT. OF
THOSE VETERAN SO THERE IS A.
FUTURE POPULATION.
THAT COULD BENEFIT
FROM.
EVERY VISIT OF THE SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED TO VETERANS.
UP WE KNOW THAT THERE'S. A
GROWING.
ARM BUT USE OF COMMUNITY BASED
FACILITIES.
AND COMMUNITY BASED OPERATIONS.
AND VETERANS ARE LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE IF YOU HAVE A CHOICE.
THAT TO STAY HOME. TO GET THE
CARE THAT YOU NEED YOU'D LIKE TO
BE AT HOME.
YOU WANT TO BE CLOSE TO YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR GRANDKIDS YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO WALK TO THE
PARK AND GO TO THE MOVIE THEATER
AND ENJOY THE RESTAURANTS. THAT
HAVE FORMED OF OF OF A PART OF
YOUR LIFE.
AND SO.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING IN THAT
DIRECTION A AS WELL.
NO OTHER STATE THAT WE REVIEWED
ON THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
FUNDS THEIR STATES AWAY THE
CALIFORNIA DOES.
THAT WE ARE UNIQUE IN THAT WAY
AND SO YOU REALLY NEED TO ASK
YOURSELF WHETHER THAT IS THAT AS
A SPECIAL NICHE THAT YOU REALLY
WANT TO CONTINUE TO OCCUPY. A
AND I THINK THAT WHAT.
THE SECRETARY IS DOING. IS
ENSURING THAT THERE WILL BE A
VIGOROUS EXAMINATION OF THE
DIFFERENT MODELS.
THAT ARE AT WORK ON IN THE
COUNTRY.
BOB WE HAD A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU'VE HEARD
MANY OF THEM.
AND THAT WE'VE GOT A LIST OF
QUESTIONS THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO ADDRESS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT SHOULD
YOU CHOOSE IT.
TO DECIDE THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
USE YOUR TIME.
BUT QUITE FRANKLY YOU'VE GOT TWO
OTHER PEOPLE ON THIS PANEL WHO
ARE FAR BETTER THAN I.
AT TALKING ABOUT THE SPECIFICS
OF THE TOPIC THAT YOU HAVE AGAIN
LET ME EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THAT MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. OF FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT DEBT TO VETERANS.
THAT AND PLEASE KNOW THAT LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION.
STANDS READY BUT TO CONTINUE TO.
ASSIST YOU.
BOB IN ADVANCE IN THE AGENDA FOR
SERVICES FOR VETERANS.
JACK NUMBER AS A WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
HERE TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
A REPORTER OFFICE PUBLISHED LAST
YEAR IN RESPONSE TO SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE ADOPTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE. IN THE REPORT
WE DISCUSSED VARIOUS SERVICES
OFFERED TO VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT MAINLY WITH THE
FOCUS ON THE VETERAN HOMES
OPERATED BY CAL THAT SO MY
COMMENTS TODAY WILL PRIMARILY
FOCUS ON THE VETERAN HOME
SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDING A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF HOW THE VETERAN
HOMES ARE FUNDED.
DISCUSSING CURRENT CAPACITY IN
DEMAND.
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
RECENT CHANGES TO THE BETTER
HOMES SYSTEM THAT OCCURRED AS A
PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
PROCESS AND ALSO OFFERING A
SUMMARY. OF RELEVANT BUDGET
PROPOSALS UP FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
BUDGET DELIBERATION PROCESS.
FIRST WITH REGARDS TO HOW
VETERANS HOMES ARE FUNDED THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATES.
A THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
COST TO SERVE ABOUT.
ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED VETERANS ACROSS THE
HOMES IT IS EXPECTED THAT THESE
GENERAL FUND COSTS WILL BE
OFFSET BY HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS. AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS
COME INTO THE STATE
I'M MONTHS ARE POTENTIALLY YEARS
AFTER KOSTER ACTUALLY ANCHORED.
I ONCE BECOME FOR THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS THE NET GENERAL
FUND COST IS VENN ESTIMATED TO
BE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
AS AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE WE DO
NOT BUT THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS BUT THE STATE
RECEIVES DOES VERY BY THE LEVEL
OF CARE VETERANS ARE RECEIVING
IN THE HOMES. AND ALSO A
VETERANS DISABILITY STATUS.
NEXT WITH REGARDS TO CAPACITY
I'M BASED OFF OF THE MOST RECENT
DATA WE WERE ABLE TAX.
VERIFY THAT THE FIGURE IN OUR
REPORT THAT WAS HANDED OUT ON
PAGE FIFTEEN FIGURE TEN THAT
SHOWS THE I'M CAPACITY IN
COMPARISON TO THE WAIT LIST IS
STILL I'M ACCURATE.
MEANING THAT BASED ON RECENT
DATA WE SEE THAT DEMAND HASN'T
CHANGED MUCH SINCE WE PUBLISHED
OUR REPORT AND WE SEE THAT
ACROSS ALL HOMES.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LOWER
LEVELS OF CARE SUCH AS DOMUS
SILLERY OR INDEPENDENT LIVING
FACILITIES FOR THE MOST PART.
DEMAND OR PEOPLE ON THE WAIT
LIST THERE'S.
IT IT SEEMS TO LINE WITH
CURRENT CAPACITY WITHIN THE
HOMES HOWEVER THERE IS A HIGH
LEVEL OF UNMET DEMAND FOR
SKILLED NURSING AND MEMORY CARE
BATS.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT ON A
PER HOME BASE AS CAPACITY IN
DEMAND DOES VERY WITH SOME
HOMES.
I'M NOT BEING ABLE TO CUT
ACCOMMODATE THAT THE CURRENT
DEMAND THAT THEY HAVE FOR
DOMICILIARY PADS AND ALSO OTHER
HOMES HAVING BEING GET PADS
ACROSS VARIOUS LEVELS OF CARE.
IN ADDITION IN THE REPORT WE
DISCUSSED THAT.
IN THIS LARGER CONVERSATION OF
CAPACITY WHILE BASIC MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE
THE HOMES CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO TAKE IN
RESIDENTS WITH COMPLEX AND
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS.
MOVING ON FROM CAPACITY IN THE
REPORT WE ALSO REACHED RAISED A
NUMBER OF ISSUES.
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
THAT DELIVER AT THE SERVICE
DELIVERY WITHIN THE HOMES AND AS
A PART OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET PROCESS SOME OF
THESE ISSUES WERE WERE ADDRESSED
THROUGH LEGISLATION.
PRIMARILY ONE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A LONG TERM FASTER PLAN FOR THE
VETERANS HOMES. IN WHICH CALVET
WILL ASSESS THE FUTURE LONG TERM
CARE NEEDS OF VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND POTENTIAL DEMAND.
I'M FOR VETERANS HOMES IN HOPES
THAT BASED OFF OF THESE FINDINGS
OF THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT WE WOULD
BE IN A BETTER POSITION TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO ADOPT THE VETERAN
HOMES SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD TO
MEET FUTURE DEMAND.
IN ADDITION ANOTHER CHANGE THAT
CAME THROUGH BUDGET RELATED
LEGISLATION WAS A PRIORITIZATION
OF VETERANS WITH HIGHER
DISABILITY LEVELS FOR
ADMISSIONS.
THESE VETERANS TYPICALLY RECEIVE
HIGHER FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS
FOR THE COST OF CARE WHICH COULD
POTENTIALLY RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS IN FUTURE YEARS.
AS A PART OF THE MASTER PLAN
CALVET WAS TASKED TO ASSESS
POTENTIAL TRADEOFFS IN
PRIORITIZING VETERANS WITH
HIGHER. DISABILITY I'M RATINGS
THAN THOSE VETERANS.
.
AND THEN OTHER VETERANS AND THE
POTENTIAL COSTS AND SAVINGS THAT
THIS DECISION MAY HAVE.
OTHER POINTS THAT WERE I HAVE
RAISED IN THAT BUDGET RELATED
LEGISLATION ALSO INCLUDED.
.
IF WITHIN THE MASTER PLAN CALVET
DISCUSSING HOW THE HOMES COULD
BETTER SERVE VETERANS WITH
COMPLEX BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. AND ALSO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STREAMLINED
ONLINE APPLICATION SYSTEM FOR
VETERANS.
I AM TECH AND MY BRIEF REMARKS I
JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON TO BUDGET
RELATED PROPOSALS THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING WITH REGARD TO
THE VETERAN HOME SYSTEM. OUR
OFFICE IS STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF ANALYZING THESE PROPOSALS BUT
AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL BOTH RELATE
TO THE.
VETERANS HOME IN YOUNTVILLE.
ONE IS A PROPOSAL TO BEGIN
PRELIMINARY PLANS THAT WOULD
CONSTRUCT A SKILLED NURSING AND
MEMORY CARE FACILITY LARGELY TO
REPLACE THE CURRENT SKILLED
NURSING AND MEMORY CARE
FACILITIES WITH ANYA BELL. THE
OTHER UP BOZELL IS TO REDUCE OUR
IT IS TO CONVERT THE AND.
IS TO CONVERT CURRENT DOUBLE.
DOMICILIARY ROOMS INTO SINGLE
DOMICILIO ROOMS WITHIN THE YOUNG
FILLED FACILITY AGAIN WERE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
INFORMATION BUT AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL SOME OF THE. WHAT ONE OF
THE MAIN KEY QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE IS HOW DOES THIS ADDED
THESE PROPOSALS FIT WITHIN THE
LARGER CONTEXT OF THE MASTER
PLAN? AND AND THE ATTEMPTS OF
NOT ONLY.
IDENTIFYING POTENTIAL CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE MADE WITHIN ONE
HOUSE OF WITHIN ONE HOME BUT IN
THE CONTEXT OF. DEVELPING A
PLANET FOR CHANGES ACROSS ALL
THE HOMES.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
WHY DON'T WE WAIT TILL THE?
AND.
FOR ALL HER QUESTIONS IF YOU
DON'T MIND. LET'S GO TO OUR LAST
SPEAKER COMMEND CHAIRMAN BURTON
CHESNY.
WEARING A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
HATS AND THE VICE CHAIR VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS OF AMERICA.
FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD NONPROFIT
BASED IN SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ITS
SUBSIDIARY.
VETERANS HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND WHERE THE
PROCESSDEVELOPING A NUMBER OF
PERMITS SUPPORTIVE IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FACILITIES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OUR BOARD MEMBER OF. A CHASM OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES OF
SIMILAR AGENCIES AROUND.
CALIFORNIA FORMER BED BOARD
MEMBER THE NCH BI NATIONAL
COALITION FOR HOMELESS VETS.
AND A FORMER CONSULTANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE. ARM AND I'M HAPPY TO
SEE THAT YOU'VE UPGRADED
POSITION THE STANDARD THAT YOU
APPLY FROM WHEN I HELD SO.
.
BUT I'VE BEEN WORKING IN.
OF THE HOMELESS VETERAN ISSUE
FOR ABOUT FOR DECADES.
AND SO THAT'S SORT OF THE FOCUS
I BRING TO IT IS HARDLY HELP
THAT POPULATION.
%
WHICH IS THE MOST AT RISK AND
THEY HIGHEST HARDEST TO SERVE.
BEFORE GOING TO THAT THOUGH I
WANT TO.
DEVELOPMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS HEARING ARE I'M A VIETNAM
VET LIKE THE VICE CHAIR. ARE
AND%
IT IS SO WONDERFUL TO SEE THE
DRAMATIC.
CHANGE AND THE POLITICS AROUND
VETERANS FROM OUR ERA TO THIS
I WAS JUST PHENOMENAL AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING PART OF THAT THAT
CHANGE LET'S. JUST FROM I JUST
CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH BECAUSE
IT WAS SO DIFFERENT THAT.
.
BUT HER BACK TO HOMELESS VETS
ON.
A.
WE ARE SEEN AS THE SECRETARIES
TO QUITE A LITTLE BIT AN
INCREASING.
ACUITY OF THE ISSUES FACING
THAT POPULATION.
THEY ARE AGING.
THEY ARE HAVING.
MORE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SOME OF THAT IS THE DRAMATIC
BRAIN INJURIES THAT THE
SECRETARY TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THAT IS THE. OPIATE ADDICTIONS
THAT WERE.
AND PART OF THE CAME OUT OF THE
SERVICE AND CAME OUT OF THE A
CARE WITH THOSE OPIATE
ADDICTIONS.
ARM PART OF IT IS THE FACT THAT
I COMPARED TO THE TYPICAL
DRAFTEE IN VIETNAM THE AMOUNT OF
COMBAT THEY SEE IS FAR GREATER.
AND YOU HAVE A. GREATER
DIVERSITY IN THE POPULATION OF
THOSE VETS THAT IN VIETNAM
PARTICULARLY WITH WOMEN.
WHO BRING ALL OF THE SAME?
COMBAT EXPOSURE ISSUES THAT THE
MEN BRING ON THE OPIATE
ADDICTION ISSUES AND THEN THE
SEXUAL TRAUMA AND THE
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
ISSUES. OF THAT THE WOMEN IN THE
SERVICE.
HA HA EXPERIENCE AND ADD INTO
THAT EXPERIENCE THAT THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS IT SO ARE. AND. A
DIFFERENT POPULATION TO SERVE IN
THE.
.
A. OF OUR COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS WE RUN. A SEVERAL
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FACILITIES
AND PERMITS MORE HOUSING FOR
THOSE ARE TRADITIONAL FACILITY
TRANSITIONAL FACILITIES THAT
WERE USED.
TO BRING FOLKS IN OFF THE STREET
ALL OUR FOLKS ARE FORMER OR WERE
HOMELESS TOOK TO COME IN.
NOT ORIGINALLY WERE IN BARRACKS
LIKE ENVIRONMENTS
AND THEN AND OF MULTIPLE BED
UNITS BEDROOMS.
HARD TO SERVE UP THAT WOMEN'S
POPULATION AND SO BENNETT AND
TAKES TIME TO BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SERB THAT POPULATION WERE DOING
THAT.
BUT FRANKLY WE'RE.
WERE BEHIND THE CURVE THE CURVE
IN DOING IT.
.
THE.
IN. IRONICALLY IN ONE OF OUR
FACILITIES IN YOUR REFILL WE
BUILT A A A. NEW FACILITY
TRANSITIONAL FACILITY DEDICATED
SPACE FOR WOMEN.
THAT WERE IMMEDIATELY OCCUPIED
BY TRANSSEXUAL MEN.
AND SO THERE WAS NO PLACE.
FOR THE WOMEN.
SO IT'S IN A CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT CHANGING POPULATION
AND WE'RE ALL HAVING TO COPE
WITH IT TAKES RESOURCES.
AND I WOULD URGE.
THAT AS YOU LOOK FORWARD.
THAT. THIS LIMITED RESOURCE THAT
WE HAVE
AT THE STATE TO SERVE THIS
POPULATION.
OUT WE REALLY FOCUS ON THAT
HARDEST TO SERVE THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST NEED ARM. OF THE
HOMELESS AND AT RISK GRATTERI.
A.
THAT.
.
WE HAD BEGUN A.
S. OF REDUCING THAT NUMBER
SIGNIFICANTLY RECENT ACCOUNTS
THAT HAVE AND WE HAVE WORKERS TO
SEE WHAT THE MOST RECENT POINT
CURRENT TIME COUNTS ARE GOING TO
PRODUCE. ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER LA WENT UP FIFTY PERCENT
YEAR OVER YEAR OF HOMELESS
VETERANS.
WE'VE MOSTLY WORK IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE SEEING. A
NOT QUITE AS HIGH BUT
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN OUR
HOMELESS POPULATIONS AS WELL.
AND SO.
THIS KIND OF A. GROUPINGS OF
FOLKS FOR THAT FOR THE HOMES.
YOU HAVE THE EIGHTEEN RARE ARM.
AND AND THE VET WHO.
IS COMING OUT OF OUR
TRANSITIONAL PROGRAMS WITH
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND MIGHT BE YOUNGER BUT
IS NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK.
WERE THROUGH PROP FORTY ONE WERE
ABLE TO NOW ABLE TO START
BUILDING WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING. ITEM AND INVENTORY OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
THAT POPULATION OF THAT.
WORK CLEARLY LOOKING AT THIS
MASTER PLAN OF HOW WE BETTER
UTILIZE THE HOMES TO SERVE THAT.
SIMILAR AGING.
AND.
A HUB VETERAN WHO'S NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO RETURN SUCCESSFULLY
TO REALLY.
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
.
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S A
VERY PUEDEN AS THE VICE CHAIR
POINTED OUT.
UNLESS YOU CAN COME UP.
WITH A VIABLE PLAN TO IN WORLD
CONFLICT.
.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO NEED
THAT RE THOSE RESOURCES OF THE
VET HOMES TO SERVE THIS
POPULATION.
ARM AND A CON. THE ACUITY OF
THEIR NEED WILL INCREASE THEIR
POPULATIONS WILL INCREASE AND
SO.
I WOULD HATE TO SEE THIS
AUCTION AWAY.
THAT RESOURCE
SERVE NINE VETERAN NEEDS.
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA BE RABBIT
REVENUE GENERATING IN SOME
FASHION THAT WE NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT LEVERAGING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
ARE EVER NOT MY I THINK THAT.
A RECOMMENDATION I WOULD MAKE
WITH RESPECT TO YOU HAN FELL OF.
A BECAUSE I THINK IT'S BEST
SUITED FOR. USES OTHER
POPULATION YOUNGER POPULATION OF
VETS.
WHO? TYPICALLY FEW YEARS AFTER
THEY COME OUT.
THERE THEIR BRIDGES HAVE BEEN
BURNED THERE.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES AND
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH IT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES OF GOT
TO THE POINT. WHERE THEY'RE
EITHER EITHER? THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE BROKEN UP THEY'VE LOST
THEIR JOBS THERE AT IMMINENT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS IF NOT
HOMELESS ALREADY.
BET HAVE NOT.
GONE SO FAR DOWN THAT PATH.
THAT.
BECAUSE THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO.
WITH GOOD TREATMENT AND
TRAINING.
PETE RETURNED TO CIVILIAN LIVES
AND I THINK IF IN LOOKING AT THE
ART FILL RESOURCE.
ONE OF MY QUIBBLES WITH. A OF
MY FRIEND. MR NOVICE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE FACT THAT
YOU SUGGESTED THAT WE SHOULD USE
YOUR UP FILL FOR VETERANS
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING.
POINTING TO
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY IN NAPA
VALLEY AS A SOURCE OF JOBS WITH
THAT TRAINING.
AND.
I THINK.
A YOUNG PHIL WOULD BE EXCELLENT
FOR A POPULATION OF VETS FOR
TRAINING.
BUT NOT IN HOSPITALITY BECAUSE
IN NAPA VALLEY BECAUSE THOSE
FOLKS MAY GET JOBS BUT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
VALLEY.
SO WHIPPED BEING TRAINED FOR
HOSPITALITY DOESN'T YOU CHIU
NECESSARILY LEVEL LIVABLE WAGE
AND MUCH OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT IF WE TARGETED
THROUGH THE TAP PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
THROUGH THE NETWORK OF VETERANS
SERVICE AGENCIES IN CASPER AND
ELSEWHERE. AND IDENTIFIED THAT.
THAT SUBSET OF VETS
WHO.
WITH QUICK MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
CAMERA TO RETURN TO PRODUCTIVELY
LIVES.
YOU KNOW OUR PROGRAMS ARE SIX
OF. THE RC.
A ARE TRANSITIONAL PROGRAM OF
THAT HAVE GRADUATES.
TYPICALLY AFTER TEN MONTHS TO A
YEAR. NINETY PERCENT OF OUR
GRADUATES ARE SUCCESSFUL AND
PERMANENT HOUSING AFTER GRADUATE
AFTER THEY COMPLETE OUR PROGRAM.
SO WE TARGET A.
ARE A GROUP OF VETS.
WHO ARE YOUNGER?
WHO ARE HEADED DOWN A PATH
TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS MAYBE CHEST
ON IT?
ARM AND A PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
ON FEEL FOR A EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME.
WITH COULD MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
AND COUPLED WITH AN EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL.
THE TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
OF THEIR RESOURCES TO DUTY THE
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS THROUGH VH
IT FOR THE VETERANS HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROGRAM.
A THROUGH OF OTHER SOURCES.
THAT YOU COULD HAVE A VETERANS.
YA FEEL VETERANS ACADEMY.
THAT COULD
A REALLY CHANGE YOUNG VETERANS
LIVES
I HELP THEM ADDRESS THE REAL
ISSUES RETURNED TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND RECLAIM THEIR
FUTURES.
I'D SAY A.
A.
THAT PLACE BUT FACILITY HAS A IT
HAS PROVIDED ACTUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT AND A VARIETY OF
RESOURCES. YOU HAVE THE
POLITICAL SUPPORT UP AROUND
VETERANS TO ATTRACT.
THAT A PARTICULAR IF THE STATE
IS HELPING BRING IT TOGETHER.
AND TO ATTRACT THE CORPORATE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY
VIA A OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
HAVING OF A LIFE OF SUGGEST
THAT MIGHT BE. DESERVE SOME
RESEARCHERS THAT THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF STUDIES.
OF IRAN.
CORPORATION BY THE LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS COUNCIL.
ON THE DRAMATIC SAVINGS THAT
HOUSING THE HOMELESS PROVIDES.
ON MOST OF THOSE INNER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND SAVINGS OR.
AND THE STATEMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE ISSUES.
POLICE ISSUES.
.
SO WHILE HOUSING HOMELESS VETS
MAY COST THE STATE'S OF MONEY.
WE'RE SAVING THE PUBLIC TREASURY
BY OFF SOME OF THOSE ESTIMATES
AS MUCH AS THREE TIMES THE COST.
SO HOW CAN WEEK SOMEHOW RECOUP
SOME OF THAT COST TO HELP PAY
FOR THE VETS. OF BECAUSE THERE
CERTAINLY SAVINGS TO BE HAD.
FROM OUR A HOUSING THE HOMELESS
OF PARTICULAR HOMELESS VETS TO
PUT THEIR LIFE AND LIMB AT RISK
FOR THE REST OF HIS.
ARMANDO DOWN TO ABOUT ONE
PERCENT WILLING TO DO THAT.
SO IT SEEMS A.
A SMALL PRICE TO PAY.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND.
AYE I DO HAVE TO SAY OF THE
UNITED STATES DOES.
.
I REALLY OWE ARE VIETNAM VETS AS
YOU MENTIONED A BIG APOLOGY AND
I'M VERY GLAD THAT. ATTITUDE
TOWARD VETERANS.
IS SO MUCH MORE.
POSITIVE NOW THAN WHEN OUR MEN
AND WOMEN RETURN TO WAS REALLY
APPALLING MOTHER TREAT IT.
SO. I GUESS FIVE FIRSTS ON
QUESTION FOUR.
MISTER NAVA.
YEAH DOES.
DO YOU SEE THAT WITH ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME OUT OF
THE REPORT THAT'S.
CAL THAT IS IS MOVING.
TOWARD.
.
TOWARD THEM OR THE LEGISLATURE
IS MOVING TOWARD THEM OR IS
THERE SOMETHING STILL THAT YOU
THINK REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED BY EITHER THE
LEGISLATURE OR CALVET.
NOT LIKE BUT I DO THINK AT THEIR
HOUSE.
BEEN SOME SIGNIFICANT.
.
ADVANCEMENTS WITH RESPECT TO.
THE UP A CONCERN FOR VETERANS
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
.
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T MANAGE WHAT
YOU CAN'T MEASURE.
AND WHEN THE.
.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT THE THE
DEPARTMENT
THE VETERANS AFFAIRS.
BOB PUTTING TOGETHER THEIR.
PLAN.
AND IDENTIFYING WHAT'S GOING ON
AT THE HOMES.
THAT'S GONNA BE THE BEGINNING OF
IDENTIFYING FOR PEOPLE.
WHAT?
WHAT'S GOING ON HOW MUCH DOES IT
COST AND HOW THEY CAN DO IT
BETTER.
I AND WE SUSPECT THAT THROUGH
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO FIND IT
THERE ARE ECONOMIES THAT CAN BE.
IMPLEMENTED THAT WILL MAKE OTHER
FUNDS AVAILABLE TO THE SORT OF
THING THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY BEYOND JUST WITHIN
THE HOMES.
I AM I WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST.
THAT.
AS WE TALK ABOUT A VETERANS AND
JOB TRAINING AT ANY GIVEN
ARGUMENT FROM ANYBODY THAT
VETERANS OUGHT TO BE.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A JOB
TRAINING MANY VETERANS COME OUT
OF THE MILITARY WITH SPECIFIC
JOB SKILLS BUT I WILL. I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA TELL YOU ABOUT AN AREA
WHERE I THINK THAT TIME WOULD
BE.
WELL SPENT
AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH.
WHAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES LIKE
THEME EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT?
ARE YOU SEEN WHEN THEY CALCULATE
THE CAREERS OF TOMORROW.
WHETHER JOBS
THAT ET DE IS IDENTIFYING AS
BEING JOBS FOR THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE
LOU HOOVER COMMISSION HAS
STARTED TOTHE PEAK UNDER THE
COVERS OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
AND SOME OF WHAT WE ARE ASKING
IS HOW DO WE APPLY ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND HOW DO WE
ANTICIPATE JOB TRAINING NEEDS IN
THE FUTURE GIVEN WHAT'S LIKELY
TO BE THE IMPACTS OF ARTIFICIAL.
INTELLIGENCE AND WHAT YOU'LL
FIND IS THAT STATE AGENCIES.
THAT HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
DOING THAT KIND OF PLANNING ARE
LOOKING INTO REVIEW MER AND ARE
NOT LOOKING STRAIGHT AHEAD.
AND IT WOULD BE A A A TRAVESTY.
TO THINK ABOUT INVESTING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
IDENTIFYING JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE WHO
DESPERATELY NEED IT WHEN THERE
HASN'T BEEN THE WORK DONE
NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
THEY GET THROUGH THE TRAINING.
THERE'S A JOB THERE FOR THEM. WE
DON'T WANT TO TRAIN THEM FOR
JOBS ARE GOING TO DISAPPEAR AND
IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GO. BUT AS
IT RELATES TO THE.
SO THAT'S NOT REALLY PART OF
OUR REPORT BUT IT'S SOMETHING I
THINK AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
HEALTH OF VETERANS AND WHAT'S
GOING TO BE.
HOW DO WE PROVIDE FOR VETERANS
IN THE FUTURE WITH EMPLOYMENT
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
REALLY HAVE TO BE ASKING?
OURSELVES WE NEED BE ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS ABOUT DATA.
IN EVERY KIND OF ENDEAVOR THAT
WE ENGAGE AND WE FIND IN LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION AT ONE OF
THAT.
ONE OF THE REGULAR SHORTCOMINGS
BUT WITH RESPECT A PROGRAMS IS.
A A FAILURE AT THE INITIATION OF
THE PROGRAM WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE OR
LEGISLATIVE.
TO REQUIRE COMPILATION OF DATA
IN A FORM THAT ANYBODY CAN LOOK
AT SO THAT YOU CAN FIGURE OUT
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE GETTING
THE JOB DONE THERE'S A PART OF
ME LIBERA CYNICISM IT'S STILL
ALIVE. THAT SAYS THE PERHAPS
THEY DO THAT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
MEASURE YOU CAN'T.
REPRIMAND IF YOU DON'T HAVE
STANDARDS.
IF THERE'S NOTHING THAT HEY
FELL AWAY FROM WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSE TO DO YOU CANCEL YOUR
DOING A BAD JOB GOES AGAINST A
WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT. WHERE
MY METRICS HA HA YOU CAN MAKE
THEM YOU DIDN'T MAKE ME HAVE
THEM SO I'M SAYING IS THAT YOU
GO THROUGH THESE THINGS YOU
OUGHT TO BE THINKING AS WELL
ABOUT METRICS TO MEASURE PROGRAM
ACTIVITY?
BOB I I THINK THAT AGAIN I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE VETERANS AFFAIRS HAVE
DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB WITH
RESPECT TO LOOKING AT THESE UP
RECOMMENDATIONS AND. DECIDING
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THEM
I'D I'D I DON'T HAVE ANY. ANY
COMPLAINTS.
OKAY AND THEN.
AND I GUESS ANY OF THIS THREE
OF YOU COULD ANSWER I'VE BEEN
POLICE HERE THEY.
.
YOU KNOW THE DISCUSSION OF A
REDUCING OR ELIMINATING
DOMICILIARY AND.
CARE. AND AND HOW DO WE DO THIS
WITHOUT ABANDONING OUR DUTY TO
OUR VETS.
BUT WHAT WHAT.
.
HOW DO WE MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION?
YEAH I THINK ONE OF THE SCARIEST
STUBHUB THINGS AND ANYBODY. CAN
HEAR IS THAT WERE YOU KNOW GRANT
TAKE WAY HOME.
WITHOUT THAT WOULD MAKE ME
NERVOUS BITE MY WIFE CALLED ME
UP AND SAID GUESS WHAT THE HOUSE
IS GONE. I I I WOULD BE VERY
UPSET AND ANXIOUS ABOUT ALL
THAT.
NOW THAT I'VE DONE ANYTHING
WRONG I'M JUST SAYING IT.
BUT.
SO PART OF PART OF WHAT WE'D A
PART OF WHAT I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO DO WITH A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
AND THIS IS ALSO ABOUT EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC IN THE VETERANS.
IF YOU HAVE AS AS WE'VE SEEN
ACOSTA BED OF HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER BED.
YOU SAY THAT TO ANYBODY
UNDERGONE LIKE JUST GIVE ME A
VOUCHER.
ALRIGHT I CAN PROBABLY FIND ME
PRETTY DECENT HOTEL ROOM ON A
CALLS FOR. A HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BUT IF WHAT YOU DO IS SAY. WE
CAN ENGAGE WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT DO HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DEAL WITH VETERANS AND
PROVIDE SERVICES WE CAN DO THAT
EITHER IN THEIR HOME. OR WE CAN
DO THAT IN A FACILITY THAT IS.
NOT NECESSARILY YOUR HOME BUT
THEN AGAIN NOT A PERMANENT. BAD
FOR SOMEONE ALL THE TIME YOU CAN
GENERATE SOME OF THAT MONEY FROM
IT RE VISITING. THROUGH THE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF THE EXISTING
HOMES.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT WE HAVE
TO BE CONSISTENT AND AND WE HAVE
TO.
INSURE THAT VETERANS UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'VE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL HONOR OUR
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE.
AND ONE OF THE BETTER WAYS TO DO
IT IS TO LOOK THROUGH THE SYSTEM
FIND THE INEFFICIENCY SQUEEZE
THOSE OUT. AND THEN TAKE THE
MONEY THAT YOU RECOVER.
FROM THAT TO PUT IT INTO
SERVICES THAT ARE BETTER.
APPLY TO VETERANS.
MAYBE IN THEIR OWN HOMES.
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE WOULD
NOTICE WHILE IS THERE ARE
VARIOUS WAYS IF THE LEGISLATURE
WERE CONSIDERING THAT TO DO IT
EACH WITH THEIR OWN TRADE OFF
SO.
ANY CONSIDERATION OF CHANGING
SOME OF THE MIX IN THE.
LEVELS OF CARE SERVICES PROVIDE
IN THE VETERANS HOME WOULD HAVE
TO REQUIRE SOME INVESTIGATION OF
WHAT THE TRADE OFFS ARE. AND
THEN IDENTIFYING ARE THERE WAYS
TO ADDRESS ANY POTENTIAL UNMET
NEED GIVEN JUST THE PROJECTION
OF FUTURE NEEDS AND RECOGNIZING
THAT.
AND ASSESSMENT TODAY OF FUTURE
DEMAND.
MIGHT NOT REFLECT AN ASSESSMENT
THAT WE CAN DO FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW JUST GIVEN THE THAT CHANGING
ON DEMOGRAPHICS WITHIN THE
POPULATION AS WELL.
I THINK YOU SHOULD LOOK AT IT IS
WE HAVE THIS INVENTORY OF HOMES
BEING DEVELOPED UNDER THE H. P..
THAT ARE PERMANENT.
ALL VERGE ALL OF THEM TO DATE
HAVE BEEN I'M ALMOST ALL OF THEM
BEEN PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
ARM. AND A. HAS THAT INVENTORY
IT'S DEVELOPED.
ARE IT CAN ABSORB SOME OF THAT
DOM POPULATION.
AND THAT DOWN POPULATION CAN
THEN BE TRANSFERRED.
A. LOT TWO OTHER PURPORT
REPURPOSE FOR OTHER THANKS
BECAUSE YOU WILL HAVE THIS ARE
THEIR INVENTORY OF HOUSING
LOCATED NEAR WERE PUT FOLKS ARE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES THROUGH V.
H. H. PRE. ELECTED NO PLACE LIKE
HOME FUNDING THAT'S COMING
ONLINE HOPEFULLY.
AND SO THERE IS WE CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE IT SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT'S GONNA BE AWHILE FOR IT.
TO GET GET BUILT.
A BUT IT CAN RELIEVE SOME OF THE
NEED FOR THE DOM SPACE SO IT CAN
BE REPURPOSED FOR OTHER THINGS.
AND ANOTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE
IS IN OUR REPORT REDUCED.
MENTIONED THAT DEPENDING ON THE
PRIORITIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SETS OUT IN PARTICULARLY WHICH
VETERANS. WOULD YOU LIKE THE
VETERANS HOME SYSTEM TO FOCUS ON
IF THEY'RE POTENTIALLY HOMELESS
VETERANS UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY.
WOULD JUST PROPORTIONALLY
HOMELESS VETERANS TO HAVE A
LEVEL OF COMPLEX BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
ALTERNATIVE MODELS OF CARE.
THERE'S A GAP IN RESOURCES
THEY'RE. TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THEN WHAT IS THE CURRENT VALUE
OF THE VETERAN HOME SYSTEM FOR
SOME OF THESE MORE DIFFICULT
POPULATIONS THAT JUST
TRADITIONALLY HAVE TROUBLE.
.
I'M ME.
ADD A DO TROUBLE IN THEIR HEALTH
BUT THEN ALSO THERE HOUSING
STABILITY.
ANOTHER KEY POINT IN TERMS OF
WORKING WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES IN
WASHINGTON.
IS MAINTAINING THE AND HOPEFULLY
EXPANDING THE VASH PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES BOTH THE RENTAL
SUBSIDY AND THEIR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES
THAT MAKE THESE YOUR PROP FORTY
ONE FUND BE HHB FUNDED PROJECTS
WORK.
I CAN'T.
HOW ONTO SCORES YOU DE AND ORDER
PARTICULARLY IN HIGH COST AREAS?
YOU CAN'T PENCIL OUT A PERMIT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WITHOUT A
PROJECT BASED.
VOUCHERS SYSTEM FOR THE SUBSIDY.
AND YOU CAN'T MANAGE A
POPULATION OF CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS.
OF VETERANS WITHOUT GOOD
PROFESSIONAL CASE MANAGEMENT
ONSITE.
WHICH COMES WITH THAT THE
NATIONAL
MISTER VOEPEL YOU HAD SOMETHING
JUST SO THAT. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A HOUSING IN THE TORY HOW
MANY UNITS ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
OF THE EIGHT HP IS GONNA
PROBABLY PRODUCE CLOSE TO THREE
THOUSAND UNITS TO.
EN I HAVE NO PLACE LIKE HOME I
DON'T KNOW I HAVEN'T SEEN WHAT
PROJECTIONS THAT COULD PRODUCE
AS WELL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL THE ARROW.
WELL I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
PANEL AND IT THINK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR EXPERTISE AYE
I AM.
I REALIZED AYE IN ARTFULLY ASK
THAT THE QUESTION EARLIER OF THE
SECRETARY BECAUSE REALLY WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO GET TO ON ARE ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT WITCHES.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A MENU OF OF
NEEDS IN SERVICES THAT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE. AND THE QUESTION THEN
BECOMES HOW DO YOU KIND OF
JUSTIFY WHERE YOU SPEND THE
MONEY. ON IT NOT DETRACTING FROM
ANY PARTICULAR.
INJURY HERE OR ON.
OR AT NEED BUT THERE'S LIMITED
RESOURCES AND.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE DO THIS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
LOW THAT'S THE REASON I ASKED.
ORDER OTHER STATES DOING ITS
BECAUSE IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
THAT SOMETIMES ON.
LOOKING AT HOW IT'S DONE
ELSEWHERE MAY BE UP ALESTRA
ATTEMPT BUT.
WHEN I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT IS.
IT SEEMS TO ME WHAT WE WANT TO
TRY TO DO IS VERY VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE DO WITH SENIORS WHICH
IS TO TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE. IN
THEIR HOMES AS LONG AS POSSIBLE
AND TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDES THEM WITH THE SERVICE.
FOR SERVICES THEY NEED AS
OPPOSED TO BRINGING THEM OUT AND
THEN RESUMING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE CARE. THAT MAY NOT BE KICKED
OUT POSSIBLE IN ALL INSTANCES
BUT. ON IT IT UP THE MORE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE. THE
ALTERNATIVES.
AND AND ONE OF THE AS
ALTERNATES FOR EXAMPLE MAY BE
FOR.
.
AT VETERANS THAT ARE DISABLED
HELPING THEM FIX THEIR HOME.
BOB WITH DISABILITY ACCESS
SO THAT THEY CAN MANEUVER AROUND
THERE THEIR RESIDENTS GIVEN
THEIR THEIR RIGHT THERE
DISABILITY AND THAT. THAT
DOESN'T FALL VERY CLEANLY IN
WITHIN IT ANYTHING THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BUT. BUT HAVING
THOSE AS RESOURCES ON THIS MENU
CHART MIGHT BE HELPFUL AND I'M
HOPING THAT TIME. THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE.
.
THE ANALYSIS THAT'S BEEN DONE
TE REPORT THAT'S BEEN PREPARED
CAN TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE WE WANT TO TRY TO DO IS
KEEP.
KEEP PEOPLE ON GIVE PEOPLE
SERVICES AT THE LOWEST COST BUT
REALLY RESPECTING WHERE THEIR
PLACES BUT THEN ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT WE TAKE CARE OF THE
HOMELESS BECAUSE THAT. THAT TO
ME IS IS ON.
IT'S THAT IT'S THE MOST
UNCONSCIONABLE.
AB.
PROBLEM WE HAVE WHICH IS THAT
PEOPLE RETURN AND BECAUSE OF
THEIR. THEIR.
INJURIES ARE OUR PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY END UP ON THE
STREETS.
IT'S PARTICULARLY HARD FOR US.
AS A DEVELOPER IN COULD WE WOULD
DO MOSTLY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN RURAL AREAS.
WE HAVE IT LAKE COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE THE COUNTY HAS OFFERED
US FOR FREE.
FOURTEEN ACRES.
BUILD A AND WANT US TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
VETS.
OUR PROBLEM IN MAKING THAT
PENCIL OUT WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY ALLOCATED PROJECT BASED
VOUCHERS.
THEY FAIR MARKET RENTS.
AND LIKE COUNTY OR SO LOW.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THE FINANCING
WORK.
AND SO IT'S.
IT'S TOUGH IN THOSE RURAL AREAS
ARM AND OFTEN.
THEY'RE.
WE'RE WE'RE DOING TO FACILITY
IN THE CITY OF SHASTA LAKE JUST
NORTH OF READING.
IT'S ONLY THIRTY UNITS AND WE
TRIED TO FIND PARTNERSHIP WITH
TAX CREDIT DEVELOPERS.
AND NINE WOULD DEVELOP.
PARTNER WITH US BECAUSE THERE
WAS ENOUGH RETURN OUT OF A
THIRTY UNIT PROJECT.
JEFF WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO COBBLE
TOGETHER.
THE RESOURCES DO WITHOUT A TAX
CREDIT FINANCING.
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING YOU CAN'T
GET TAX GRANT FUNDING FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WE'VE
GOTTA.
COBBLE TOGETHER BIG THAT MUCH
HARDER FOR THAT IMPORTANT
COMPONENT.
OF THE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
HAN.
BUT I YOU CAN'T USE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
FUNDING FOR TRANSITIONAL YOU
CAN'T USE MHP FORAGE SOURCES.
GEN. DOT FIGHT ANYTHING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOUR YOUR READ YOUR.
YOUR IDEA ABOUT.
IF THE IF THE HOME ISN'T
ACCESSIBLE.
THEN INSTEAD OF SPENDING HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PICK A PERSON UP AND MOVE THEM
INTO A. A STATE.
OPERATE AT HOME.
THEN.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
REEVALUATION AND RE PURPOSING IS
A WORD THAT WE'VE BEEN USING
HERE.
ALL OF THE HOMES.
AND TAKING THE REVENUES.
THAT COULD BE SAVED THAN I THAT
THAT MAKES ABSOLUTE PERFECT
SENSE.
TO HAVE TO EMPOWER SOMEONE TO
REMAIN IN THEIR HOME IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND IT'S CHEAPER TO
BRING SOMEONE IN TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO THEM HOME THAN TO
HAVE THEM IN A STATE.
RUN HOME NOW THERE THERE THERE
WILL BE THOSE VETERANS THAT HAVE
TO HAVE.
THAT INTENSIVE CARE.
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE UP IN
FACILITIES OPERATED BY THE
STATE.
I BUT I DO THINK AND I'M AND I'M
OPTIMISTIC AND I THINK IT'S WISE
FOR THIS THIS COMMITTEE. TO
CONTINUE TO ASK THE SECRETARY.
FOR UPDATES SO THAT THOSE KINDS
OF PERSPECTIVES ARE REFLECTED IN
THE MATRIX OF THE DECISION
MAKING THAT IF IT IS IT IS ONCE
AGAIN IF IF YOU CAN'T MEASURE IT
YOU CAN'T MANAGE IT. AND IF IF
IF THOSE SORTS OF THINGS ARE
IGNORED IN THE EVALUATION THEN
YOU'RE REALLY MISSING A PART OF
HOW YOU CAN USE MONIES.
RIGHT TO PUT A GRAB BAR IN
SOMEBODY'S PLACE TO DO THE RAMP
TO GET UP TO THE HOUSE TO OPEN
UP THE DOORWAYS TO MAYBE CHANGE
THE HEIGHT OF THE SINKS IN THE
BATHROOMS. WHICH ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN OTHER KINDS OF HOUSING.
ALRIGHT WELL I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO THANK THE PANEL AND.
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND AND
THE ALL THE. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THAT JOINED IN THIS IS A VERY
INFORMATIVE AND.
.
I THINK WE MIGHT HAVE SOME
PUBLIC'S
SPEAKERS HAS SO I MIGHT GO AHEAD
AND CALL YOU FORWARD.
AND.
.
THANK YOU VETERAN SITE FIGURED
LET THEM AT LEAST KIND OF HAVE A
MOMENT TO.
REYES SYNDROME.
A TERRORIST ALL SPEAKS VOTE.
AND AND.
WORKING AT A LIMIT TWO TO THREE
MINUTES. BLAMES JOHN DUNBAR THE
MAYOR OF THE TOWN THE OUT
THOUGH.
APPRECIATE.
NOW CHAIR AND.
MANY MEMBERS GIVE ME A FEW
MINUTES IS A LITTLE BIT MORE THE
THREE MINUTE SNEAK ON THE OUT
THE HOME IN PARTICULAR.
WE ARE SEEING A GENERATIONAL
SHIFT IN OUR VETERAN POPULATION.
THE POPULATION BY THE WAY IS ONE
THIRD OF OUR TOWN OF YALTA
RESIDENTS
IT'S ABOUT A THOUSAND.
MEMBERS OF THE HOME. AND BRING
WITH THEM IS A NEEDED CHANGE
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT
SERVICES AND FACILITIES.
GIVEN THAT REALITY WE NEED TO
IDENTIFY HOW TO DELIVER MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OUT PATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAMS
ADDICTION THERAPY. HOUSING
CHOICES
AS WELL AS EDUCATIONAL AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING FOR VETERANS
WHO MAY NOT NEED OR WANT
DOMICILIARY LIFESTYLE.
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
STEPS ARE LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE
TO CARE FOR OUR VETERANS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW. IS TO
SUPPORT NEW HOUSING ON THE ALTO
CAMPUS.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION WITH HOUSING FOR
VETERANS.
CARE GIVING STAFF AND THE LOCAL
NAPA VALLEY WORKFORCE.
THE TIMING IS IDEAL TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN'S MAJOR COMMITMENT IN HIS
BUDGET FOR VETERANS SERVICES AND
FACILITIES.
AND THE HOUSING BILL PACKAGE
THAT INCLUDES SUPPORT FOR
VETERANS.
MANY OF THE MORE THAN NINE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OF THE AWFUL
HOME. FIND HOUSING AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABILITY ELUSIVE
SO THEY DRIVE OVER AN HOUR EACH
DAY TO GET TO WORK.
THIS HAS REAL CONSEQUENCES ON
CHILDCARE SCHOOLING FAMILY LIFE
AND COMMUNITY BALANCE.
AS OF LAST WEEK
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED JOBS
AT THE HOME REMAINED UNFILLED IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THE COST
OF LIVING IN NAPA COUNTY.
BUILDING A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY AND OTHER SUPPORT
FACILITIES IS CRITICAL I AGREE.
SO IS THE ABILITY TO COMPETE FOR
QUALIFIED STAFF. WILL PROVIDE
THE MEDICAL CARE.
SUPPORT OF THE COMMISSION'S
REVIEW OF THE HOME I'VE REACHED
OUT TO LOCAL PARTNERS INCLUDING.
THE WORK FORCE ALLIANCE OF THE
NORTH BAY THE GAS OR FOUNDATION
NAPA UNIFIED INSANE HOLE IN THE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND CAPITAL
INVESTORS WHO ARE EAGER TO HELP
THE STATE EXECUTE MEANINGFUL
POSITIVE CHANGE FOR OUR
VETERANS.
TODAY THE TOWN'S INFRASTRUCTURE
CAN SUPPORT MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS ON THE
VETERAN SOME GROUNDS THAT'S
TODAY.
WELL THAT WOULD INCLUDE A MIX OF
SINGLE FAMILY IN MULTIPLE FAMILY
RESIDENCES.
POLICIES CAN BE PUT IN PLACE
THAT ALLOW VETERANS
AND EMPLOYEES TO RECEIVE
PRIORITY. TO QUALIFY FOR THIS OF
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS AN ADDED BENEFIT THIS IS NOT
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT STATE
FUNDING UP FRONT.
STEAD PRIVATE INVESTMENT CAN BE
USED.
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS ALSO CAN BE
USED THROUGH NONPROFIT OR
FOUNDATION PARTNERS.
TO OFFSET COSTS FOR ENERGY
SAVING BUILDING PRACTICES.
BOTH CALAVERAS FACILITIES MASTER
PLAN AND THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION'S OWN REPORT.
IDENTIFY THE POTENTIAL OF JUST
SUCH PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
TO MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES AT THE
HOME.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WHICH CHECK
OFF SEVERAL BOXES STATED AS
PRIORITIES BY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE.
AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE PROXIMITY
HOUSING.
SUPPORT OF MODERN VETERAN
SERVICES
SUPPORT OF PUBLIC EDUCATION.
ECONOMIC DIVERSITY
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION.
ZERO NET ENERGY BUILDING AND THE
ADOPTION OF BUSINESS PRACTICES
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE
EFFICIENT AND SUBSTANTIAL.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN HELP BY
SUPPORTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR OUR
VETERANS AND BY ALLOWING THE
HOME TO ENTER INTO LONG TERM
LEASES.
AT FAIR MARKET VALUE.
THAT WOULD WELCOME PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
WE CAN CREATE A MODEL THAT WOULD
BE A GOLD STANDARD FOR ALL THE
VETERANS HOMES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHILE ADVANCING THE
CORE MISSION OF SERVING OUR
VETERANS.
AND I JUST VERY QUICKLY TO ADD
IN REFERENCE TO COMMENTS MADE BY
THE PREVIOUS PANEL. THERE IS A
OF A PROGRAM CALLED THE PATHWAY
HOME THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS. IN
ONE THE BUILDINGS AT THE
VETERANS HOME IT PROVIDES
HOUSING EDUCATION TRAINING AND
TREATMENT FOR POST NINE ELEVEN
VETERANS.
AND HELP SUPPORT THEIR EDUCATION
TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WE ARE COLLECTING DATA ON THEIR
OUTCOMES
AND IT'S BELIEVE OR NOT A
COLLABORATION WITH THE FEDERAL
VA CALVET AND PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SHARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JAMES MADISON I'M A HOME MEMBER
AT THE ON FIELD HOME THIRTEEN
AND ONE HALF YEARS.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE A VERY
BRIEF COMMENT?
READING FROM CHAIRMAN IN OFFICE
DECEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY FIFTEEN
LETTER.
THE LENGTH OF TIME REQUIRED FOR
ACTION REFLECTS A SYSTEMIC ISSUE
WITH FACILITY MANAGEMENT.
REPAIRS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED.
COMMISSION URGES IMMEDIATE
ACTION
THIS LETTER COULD HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN YESTERDAY.
THE YOUNG FILL HOME.
STILL SUFFERS.
THE HOME MEMBERS THERE SUFFER.
EVERYDAY.
FROM THESE UNDER SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS.
OUR LACK OF HEAT.
SOMETIMES LACK OF HOT WATER.
AND THEN UNRESPONSIVE
MAINTENANCE.
OPERATION.
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS.
THE RESIDENCE HALLS.
SUB STANDARD FOR FIRE AND SAFETY
PER TITLE THIRTY EIGHT OF THE
CODE OF FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
AND THERE ARE OVER ONE HUNDRED
RESIDENT ROOMS THAT ARE
SUBSTANDARD IN SIZE PUT THE CODE
OF FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
AND SET A TIME OF VARAMIN FLU
OUTBREAK.
FORTUNATELY THIS IS BEEN
RECOGNIZE IT WE MUST HAVE.
SINGLE ROOMS ONLY.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF OUR
COUPLES.
AT THE RESIDENTS AT THE VETERANS
HOME AND NOT FEEL.
THERE'S A HISTORY OF
DISCIPLINARY MEETINGS WITH HOME
NUMBERS AT THE ON FILL THAT
RESEMBLE KANGAROO COURTS.
THROUGH THE EFFORTS OF HOME
NUMBERS THIS HAS RECENTLY BEEN
CHANGING.
THERE INSTANCES WHERE HOME
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN THREATENED
WITH HIGHER CARE WITHOUT MEDICAL
JUSTIFICATION.
THE.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THE.
WILLFULNESS MANAGEMENT.
OF THE CONDITIONS.
MAINTENANCE OF
A.
PREVENTIVE MAINTENANCE AT THE
HOME.
THERE WAS ALREADY MENTIONED HOW
OF DISTANCE.
IMPEDES THE ABILITY.
MAPPED OF FOR POTENTIAL
EMPLOYEES TO COME TO THE HOME.
THERE ARE.
OUR AND OTHER REASONS AS WELL.
WE'VE HAD PROBLEMS IN.
HAVING OUR.
PRINT AND BROADCAST MEDIA.
CENSORED.
.
I LIKE LIVING AT THE HOME.
BUT I SEE A MULTITUDE OF REASONS
WHY MAYBE SOME PEOPLE.
WOULDN'T CONTINUE LIVING AT THE
HOME.
MAYBE THEY DON'T WANT TO PUT UP
WITH THE SUBSTANDARD CONDITIONS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THOSE
SUBSTANDARD CONDITIONS.
ALLEVIATED.
AND.
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THAT
MUCH EFFORT.
BY.
THE ADMINISTRATION.
TO DEAL WITH THOSE PROBLEMS.
THEY'RE NOT.
THEIR NOT ON SOME MANOBO.
THEY CAN BE CORRECTED.
AND IT TAKES GOOD LEADERSHIP.
A GOOD FIRST SERGEANT.
OR A FEW NAVY.
MASTER CHIEF
THEY TAKE CARE OF THOSE THINGS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SETH REED WAS READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE CLIENTS UP
HERE TODAY FROM VIETNAM VETERANS
OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL AND MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS.
WE ALSO REPRESENT AMERICAN
UNIFORM DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA. AND VETS DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND CAL THAT. AND LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION FOR THIS HEARING.
VERY INFORMATIONAL.
AND WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXTEND.
OUR HELP IN ANY WAY THAT WE CAN
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN THIS
ONGOING.
.
EFFORT TO IMPROVE. VETERAN HOMES
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S DEAN GOT
THURMOND FIRST VICE PRESIDENT
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA AND
I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO SEE THE WORK OF THE
JOINT OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
DIRECTOR AND BESSIE ON HIS COCK
HIS STAFF THERE IS A LOT OF
CHANGE GOING ON THIS IS A VERY
VERY NEEDED.
NO I REMIND EVERYBODY THE
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA WAS
FORMED IN THE LATE SEVENTY UNDER
THE FOUNDING PRINCIPLE.
NEVER AGAIN WILL ONE GENERATION
OF VETERANS ABANDON ANOTHER.
VV A OUR JOB IS CRITICAL TO US
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT HE'S
ARACHNE AFGHANISTAN VETERANS ARE
TREATED WAY BETTER.
THEN WE WERE.
I'M NOT TALKING MEDIOCRE CARE
I'M TALKIN SUPERB CARE FOR THAT
ONE PERCENT.
WHO DOES THE HEAVY LIFTING FOR
THE OTHER NINETY NINE?
THANK YOU SIR.
ALRIGHT.
SO WITH THAT I WILL